et oui bonsoir à tous voici donc la 700
24e et dernière émission d' apostrophes
la première ayant eu lieu il y a quinze
ans et demi le 10 janvier 1975 donc
c'est la dernière émission et en même
temps c'est une première parce que c'est
la première fois qu'elle est programmé
aussi tôt dans la soirée
émission exceptionnelle par sa durée
plus de deux heures par le nombre de ses
invités plus de 80 écrivains et par la
profusion des documents tirés de la
mémoire d' apostrophes
je ne voudrais surtout pas que ce soit
eu une émission de nostalgie j'espère au
contraire que ce sera la rencontre
heureuse du passé et du présent d'un
rendez vous hebdomadaire autour du libre
ce qu'était apostrophe apostrophe ses
700 24e émission la dernière ces
portraits sont extraits de cet album
intitulé dans les coulisses d'
apostrophes qui émeut paru il ya
quelques mois aux presses de la cité que
j'ai préféré c'est dont l'auteur
appartient à cette maison il s'appelle
lucien casey lotis il est 4 heures il
est d'ailleurs dès demain à ma droite
c'est lui qui fait la calabre caméra de
droite et c'est un très bon photographe
ils adorent ils dépensent tout son
argent dans la photographie
et voilà donc qui l'a fait cet album
dans les coulisses qui m'a fait cet
album me rappelle évidemment de très
bons souvenirs j'espère que vous aurez
aussi vous aimerez la voir dans votre
bibliothèque
alors je vais d'abord vous dire ce que
ne sera pas cette émission elle ne
présentera pas un palmarès des écrivains
ce ne sera pas non plus un recensement
des exclusivités des scoops
d'ailleurs exclusivité scoop sont des
mots ce n'est jamais employé ici et elle
ne prétend pas non plus ses dernières
émissions faire un bilan littéraire ou
esquisser une histoire des idées de ces
quinze dernières années
cette ultime apostrophe se contentera de
vous présenter un florilège des bons
moments d'émission des bons moments
forts des moments forts moments
dramatiques moments drôles moments
cocasses moments d'engueulade etc
vous aurez l'occasion de revoir vincenot
ce génie si une marguerite yourcenar
albert cohen maurice genevoix
jankélévitch dumézil nabokov etc etc
mais évidemment impossible de revoir
tous les écrivains célèbres français et
étrangers qui ont marqué l'émission il
faudrait prolonger les prêts à prolonger
cette émission jusqu'à je suis pas deux
ou trois heures du matin alors car nous
sommes évidemment limitée dans le temps
mais nous sommes aussi limité dans
l'espace j'espérais accueillir les 140
auteurs
et qui sont passés au moins quatre fois
apostrophes
mais comme ce studio ne peut pas
contenir plus de 100 personnes
eh bien j'ai dû en invités que quelques
80 que les absents veuille bien
m'excuser et plus encore tous ceux qui
ne sont jamais venus à apostrophes dans
ses 15 ans et là ils sont des milliers
tous les écrivains rassemblés ici diront
au moins un mot au moins un mot celui
qu'ils ont choisi
en réponse à cette question de tous les
maux de la langue française quel est
celui que vous préférez réponse
échelonnée tout au long de la soirée
enfin quelques-uns de ces écrivains
viendront commenter les séquences tirées
de la mémoire d' apostrophes et puis
comme apostrophe a souvent accueilli des
dessinateurs et bien cabu et wolinski
temps venu les les plus souvent cités
dans cette émission
eh bien ils sont là à côté nous et
illustreront les missions de leur esprit
facétieux
alors on va commencer par des extraits
de l'émission la plus célèbre de
postroff quoique la plus atypique mais
celle qui en son temps avait fait
scandale
mais comme vous savez tous que on va
ailleurs on va vous la montrer autant le
faire tout de suite autant vous la
proposer tout de suite
voici bukowski dans ces heurts cavanna
pourquoi vous avez dit que vous avez
écrit dans votre journal que du code ce
qui était pour vous un grand écrivain
pourquoi c'est parce que c'en est un oui
mais pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi quelque
chose et bout pourquoi quelque chose est
très beau c'est comme ça j'ai lu
bukowski
j'ai pleuré de plaisir fou j'ai écrit au
fond pourquoi est ce que j'ai mais en
tout cas une fois qu'on a écrit quelque
chose et on a fait parler à des
télévisions ensuite et pour moi c'est
franchement un peu terrible
je connais beaucoup d'écrivains aux
états unis qui adorerait être ici que
moi là devant les écrans devant la
caméra tas de parler d'avoir la
possibilité de dire n'importe quoi c'est
formidable mais moi ça ne fait pas
plaisir
j'ai trouvé ce petit texte page 73 dans
l'amour est un chien de l'enfer vous
dites c'est sans doute mon enfance à
dégelis et pauline c'est sans doute vrai
qu'on passe à la personne suivante s'il
vous plaît bord personnes 6 puis 7
personnes ok catherine paysan c'est un
roman la rue montorgueil
et voilà c'est un il m'a semblé
effectivement que ce personnage dont
parlait ce clown c'est un cd c'est un
dommage alors je pourrais conseiller
vous mais moi ce que j'ai aimé sa marque
des 91 ans
je sais c'est que je sens que je
descends en communion avec lesquels
c'est pas son amour à la faire la
campagne dans son amour de la forêt de
tout ça ça ça me touche je me sens une
certaine fraternité
non non ne parlait pas pendant que
monsieur ennjimi a dit elle a raconté un
truc sur la son clown ni trail et course
qui ta gueule tu nous a dit voilà je
vais dire quelque chose leur faire dire
je t'aime pas maintenant la boue est tu
me donnes pas alors dans les affaires
dires du coach richard gasquet je te
[ __ ] mon poing dans la gueule
bonjour temps en temps quelques mots
quand elle nous emmerdent cours au
hockey ciao voir au revoir
ok mais finalement il n'y a pas
tellement la bouteille s'est écrite
américains voulaient pas l'emmener là
voilà monsieur monsieur au revoir
monsieur kavanagh c'est vrai je me
rappelle que vous étiez s'est ennuyé
après cette émission parce que vous
aviez apostrophé durement bukowski mais
comment faire autrement je me suis fait
soigner
un soir j'ai reçu des morceaux de
lettres à charlie hebdo
alors c'était d'autant plus dur pour moi
que j'étais un des tout premiers à avoir
parlé de bukowski enfin j'ai découvert
avec émerveillement ce gars là est tard
et zenitel rome d'être avec lui sur le
plateau et nous c'est possible enfin si
je me suis mis en colère c'est parce que
je ne savais pas je ne savais pas que on
va il suffit qu'on parle dans le micro
et puis en régie ont choisi je savais
pas le seul billet parce que moi le
lendemain on m'avait accusé de l'avoir
viré du plateau ce qui était faux ce qui
n'est pas vrai simplement je n'étais pas
mécontent de le voir partir ça je
reconnais d'ailleurs j'étais dans mes
petits souliers j'étais effaré parce que
j'avais lu dans un article
avant me disais qu'un jour il s'était
fait vomir sur une radio je me décide
jamais il fait la même chose je le
surveillais loger si jamais mes deux
doigts dans sa bouche c'est le scandale
figure et de la télévision et voilà lors
donc c'était quand même une émission
assez tôt quand même assez étonnante
c'était un peu un coup monté 1 il
faisait son numéro découvrir le char et
ivrogne 7 litres s'étaient enfin dire
d'ailleurs commis à moi j'étais assez
interloqué par le personnage c'est que
c'est un américain et je lui dit ciao
bien merci
alors j'ai un invité d'honneur mais mon
invité d'honneur c'est georges lubin qui
vient de publier le 24e volume jeudi via
le 24e volume de la correspondance de
george sand aux classiques garnier
alors c'est un travail de fourmi et
d'érudition d'amour aussi travail que
vous avez commencé en quelle année
georges du ben non en pense et je l' ai
commencé très tôt mais en réalité me
mettre au travail c'est seulement vers
1950 1950 1950 le travail proprement dit
mais j'avais l'idée depuis longtemps le
l'idée d'abord parce que je suis né à
20km de nos rangs ce petit village que
george sand a illustré et dont je lui
suis reconnaissant qu'elle était qu'elle
est habitée et elle est magnifié et je
me suis dit très tôt que george sand
était un personnage très tôt à 4 ans je
connaissais george sand en images parce
qu'il y avait son portrait dans ma
maison et sur ce portrait mais je
n'avais pas encore une notion de
l'orthographe
mais très tôt après 2 nous a séduit deux
ans après je me suis dit pourquoi n'y at
il pas des ce1 georges qui était mon
prénom à moi pourquoi n'at-il pas death
donc george sand m'a paru un personnage
familier mais alors georges l'ubs à
50,90 ça fait 40 ans que vous vivez dans
l'intimité parce que l'élève bien bunia
fournissent 40 ans d'intimité
george-sand alors il ya monsieur lubin
il ya madame lubin et george sand c'est
un ménage à trois exactement exactement
je remercie ma femme beaucoup parce que
ma fille menthe et délirer beaucoup de
travail matérielles affaire il y avait
des looks des copies innombrables
affaires dans des bibliothèques houle
les possibilités de faire des
photocopies et il y encore l'être au
total con
bien où il y en avait eu lieu à une
vingtaine de milles vingtaine de mines
oui mais ça c'est le dernier volume
c'est la mort de george sand donc
apparaître si si si c'est parce que de
leur pays depuis le tome premier il
m'est rentré de 3,4 à 6,8 il m'est
rentré des quantités de lettres qui
n'était pas connu keith qui m'ont été
envoyés quelques fois par des personnes
bien jambes bien aimable qui manque au
timon qui ont connu même manoeuvre au
fur et à mesure et qui se sont décidés à
sortir de leurs cartons soit ce soit des
collectionneurs soit ce soit des
descendants de correspondance george
sand et mais en quel plaisir quand même
pour passer quand même autant d'années
soit correspondance de cet écrivain qui
est un peu oubliée d'ailleurs oublié qui
était d'un peu oubliée grâce à vous
d'ailleurs elle l'est moins c'est vrai
les boissons ces deux tests cette
semaine mais vous l'adorez rbds et
pourquoi mais qu'une de strasbourg une à
paris oui mais vous les deux hangars et
je l'adorais ne me n'est pas juste non
je laime cela nourrit sûrement oui je ne
la dore papa c'est à dire que je suis
parfaitement juste à son égard et je ne
veux pas de cacher les choses que l on
lui a reproché conduire rapprochée
qu'elle nous fait à juste titre eh bien
écoutez voilà donc je suis content de
nous avoir rendu hommage à georges lubin
parce que les fait un travail
considérable sur george sand et ça
méritait bien ce coup de chapeau ça
méritait bien que vous soyez l'invité
d'honneur de ces dernières émissions d'
apostrophes et alors j'espère qu'on va
ya beaucoup d'écrivains autour de vous
et je suis j'espère que quelques-uns
dans 50 ans dans 100 ans dans 200 ans
ils auront eux mêmes un georges l'humain
qui s'intéressera leur correspondance et
peut-être aussi leurs coups de téléphone
parce que malheureusement il passe plus
de coups de fil qui ne mérite ça c'est
plus difficile mais le mot
reconnaissance d'un très bon mot de la
langue française justement parce que
dans double sens reconnaître les choses
et avoir de la route
naissances et j'ai une grande
reconnaissance à george sand qui ma
fille qui m'a fourni à moi qui étais au
petit roman chèrement chez absolument
oublier et le méritant d'être ouverts
pendant qu'elle pendant quelques années
je me suis lancée sur sept jours ce
travail que en mesurant d'ailleurs assez
bien je peux plus je m'entraînerai n'ont
pas traîné non pas quand au nombre des
trains et met au compte au nombre des
volumes lorsqu'il ya ça fait combien 24
lundi 24 5 ha bon d'écouter on applaudit
on l'applaudît
c'est vraiment formidable
alors instituteur curé paysans marin
ouvriers des gens très simples qui avait
écrit leur mémoire sont venus témoigner
apostrophes et voici celle qui à
l'époque a remporté un succès fabuleux
avec son livre une soupe aux herbes
sauvages
amy lee quarles alors est ce que ce sont
tous ces malheurs qui ont fait que vous
êtes devenu à la fois nar schiste et
pacifique scénario est de contribuer
parce que mon frère quand il est mis en
permission qui m'a raconté ces quarante
cinq journées de de vie dans les
tranchées avec des poubelles à bout avec
de la fin de lille d'abord il n'a pas
voulu rentrer dans la maison il m'a
demandé les passer par la fenêtre tout
vêtement il les a mis dans un un grand
d'achat c'est en avoir est absolument
pas maudit quand je les touche même le
lendemain parce qu'ils avaient peur de
mettre sa vermine
il m'a raconté ce que c'était que le le
front et la guerre les m'a dit que les
instituteurs son nom crier slope petits
drapeaux et on descend c'est sûr mais
sans cela la mort pour la patrie sont
n'existe comme il mariait c'est celui
d'en face et quand il aura passé la
guerre si l'heure il va il échappé comme
moi mais dis moi un petit peu moins bien
prendre la charrue repas mois sur
l'instrument de travail qu'est ce que
nous aurons si nous revenons il avait
bien raison parce qu'il est parvenu un
mode et moi je ne pourrais plus et ils
m'ont rien fait mais c'est ça c'est ça
qui font que tout le monde comprenne qui
nous ont rien fait ceux d'en face on a
inventé l'ennemi c'est une chose qui
n'existe pas d'abord moi aussi je
partais du des buvettes tous les papes
et tous les grands hommes
j'aurais bien mieux fait de négliger la
culture à point de tous les chrétiens
et puis ensuite de faire quelque chose
d'abord pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
frontières qui croyez ce soit pas
suffisant d'êtres humains mais d'être
vraiment des hommes parce que nous ne
sommes pas des hommes
tant qu'il y aura du chômage et tant
qu'il y aura de la ligue 1 est encore à
des militaires ne sommes pas des hommes
mais nous défendrons nos jours l'hiver
et puis on lui dit sympa on les laisse
partir à la guerre en cours et en
algérie n'importe où et que d'autres
zones qu'ils auront rien fait et même
prendre la vie militaire je trouve que
les femmes nous devrons faire quelque
chose
passer de responsabilité nous prenons
pas nos responsabilités
les jambes non plus d'ailleurs mais je
pense que si les âmes sociale des coudes
et insisté sur les hommes parce que les
jeunes aussi ont leur mot à dire bah je
ne suis pas féministe je le fais pas mal
au crâne
j'estime qu'on devrait d'abord des
hommes et des femmes et neuf ans plus
tard et médical c'était un sacré
personnage
alors première premier bouquet première
salve de réponse à la question donc que
je vais me poser à tous les écrivains ci
présente tous les mots de la langue
française et qu'elle est celui pour
quelques raisons d'ailleurs que ce soit
que vous préférez didier van cauwelaert
fait quoi que avec un point conjonction
n'introduisant rien sinon le doute après
une affirmation une condamnation ou une
certitude
hector bianciotti les mots abymes à
cause de l' accent circonflexe
il suffit de tourner sa profondeur si on
les lui ôte l'apim devienne un petit
trou françois weyergans depuis quelques
jours j'aime beaucoup le mot nénuphars
et surtout depuis qu'on rit de l'amputer
de son ph
jean marc roberts moi j'ai choisi avec
parce que c'est le contraire de sang
la d1000 rôle cov amoureuse
parce que c'est le plus beau patrick
cauvin basculer parce qu'on ne fait pas
exprès pierre assouline océan parce que
c'est tellement magique et qui a tout un
univers à lui seul pour le co ce temps
paul constans pardon qui vient d'obtenir
le grand prix du roman de l'académie
française
alors moi j'en choisis aucun je vais
veut tous j'en ai c'est quelques-uns et
j'en retire beaucoup
yann queffélec le mot maire m
et accents graves erreurs parce qu'il
contient le mot mer est mauvaise merci
donc c'était le premier bouquet de mots
et maintenant partons pour les états
unis dans l'état du vermont tu alexandre
soljenitsyne
avez vous toujours au fond du coeur le
désir violent vous alexandre
soljenitsyne de rentrer sur la terre
russe morse case adjoignent c'est peu
dire le désir ce désir ne me quitte pas
un instant même la certitude du retour
ne me quitte pas je ne sais d'où elle
vient
ni la situation mondiale ni celle de
l'union soviétique n'offrent aucun signe
réconfortant mais mon sentiment profond
me laisse entendre que je reviendrai
divan chez moi dans ma patrie bien que
ce soit loin d'être jeunes comme vous le
voyez j'allais vous dirai ce que c'est
bien raisonnable d'y croire encore c'est
une conviction intime que je ne pouvait
supposer que je me retrouverais un jour
en prusse orientale et dans les mêmes
conditions
j'étais comme pousser vers cet épisode
une espèce de lien intime de prémonition
playbook gadagne il y revenir à
plusieurs reprises en effet dans ma vie
j'ai pressenti d'effets physiques qui me
sont ensuite arrivés
je ne suis pas seul dans ce cas tout
homme qui ne touchent pas son intuition
qui lui fait confiance voit se réaliser
dans sa vie non pas je dirais ses sous
et non pas ses prévisions mais ses
pressentiments notre organisation est
beaucoup plus fine que ne laisse croire
la pensée matérialiste que nous avons de
nous mêmes
jean d'ormesson et jean d'ormesson et
jean daniel jean d'ormesson évidemment
ces propos étaient détenus alors qu' il
n'y avait pas la pérestroïka à la glace
n'ose donc ça paraissait invraisemblable
et votre sens ça me paraissait en effet
tout à fait invraisemblable et on dit
même que c'est lui qui avait raison mais
je me rappelle très bien qu'à l'époque
ça m'avait paru tout à fait tout à fait
délirante a fait touchant et tout à fait
d'élire jean-daniel oui ça va pas rural
et prophétique au sens où la prophétie
pourrez personnaliser la fin c'est vrai
qu'avec cette dimension de visionnaire
nous impressionner tous à ce moment là
était particulièrement
alors jean daniel vous rappelez vous sur
quoi votre déception a les coudées
propos de saulgé licite dans l'émission
qui date du 11 avril 75 c'est donc une
des premières émissions d' apostrophes
sur quoi portait votre différend qui a
été sévère avec ce gène et idées qui
vous entrer dans une polémique avec jean
d'ormesson oui c'était pas un différend
avec son génie si nos moments où il
était là rien ce qu'il faut que je vous
dise que je vous rappelle parce que nous
avons fait une émission juste auparavant
où je m'étais affirmé à votre invite
comme un inconditionnel et affaire je
n'y fais lui et que et que j'avais il me
rappelait par la journée d'ivan
denissovitch le premier cercle tout
simplement l'auteur de dostoïevski
l'auteur du souvenir la maison des morts
après quoi il ya eu une campagne contre
cette rapprochement avec avec dos quand
on a dit c'est un mauvais écrivain et
d'ailleurs des écrivains qui sont ici ce
soit candice est un très mauvais
écrivain semble-t-il pour pouvoir
escamoter le problème de fond et puis il
est arrivé à paris et il a fait une
conférence de presse à laquelle je ne
t'ai pas mais où des gens m'ont dit
c'est la preuve que tu as eu tort les
mêmes qui meurent choisi ce reproche
c'est qu'il vient de faire l'éloge de la
colonisation du vietnam par les états
unis
je me suis dit alors c'était il faut
dire que c'est au moment où les
américains quitté le vietnam so lu ment
je me suis dit je savais une chose
épouvantable ça l'a été mais je vais
absolument avoir le coeur net cet homme
que j'admire si profondément qui
comptent qui m'a ébloui et qui compte
énormément et surtout dans le milieu où
je me trouvais à ce moment là je
voudrais pouvoir lui faire dire ce que
ce dont les autres le plus alors voici
un extrait de cette émission d notamment
de la polémique qui oppose et jean
d'ormesson et jean-daniel devant ce
zénith in stupéfait
question monsieur soljenitsyne c'est
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cet
occident dans lequel vous avez été
plongé après tant de malheurs et que
vous connaissez maintenant je pense
assez bien mais je crois bien que c'est
en asie impliquez vous pensez que
donc je redis une fois de plus dans les
secouristes et donne impatienté et
quelques-uns que ma douleur et la
douleur d'un certain nombre de mes amis
le mot douleur n'est pas une inflation
sémantique s'est pas séparé un excès de
vocabulaire c'est de prendre tellement
pas votre combat d'avoir une telle
admiration pour votre combat solitaire
votre témoignage est de voir que sur
ceux qui a correspondu à vos combats en
occident ils nous sortent et depuis
quelques minutes je suis certain que
vous vous trompez vous trompez peut-être
par simple manque d'information alors
pensez vous être bien informé sur
l'occident je veux dire qu'il y a eu des
même combat que ce que vous avez menée
chez des gens qui n'avaient pas le génie
littéraire ni la détermination mais et
qui ne s'était pas des combats contre le
communisme
c'étaient des combats contre le
colonialisme c'étaient des combats
contre le capitalisme et que ces combats
là ils sont les mêmes que les vôtres
et c'est dans la construction d'un
avenir commun que nous nous voulons un
ton est d'intégrer le vôtre et tout d'un
coup voilà distant de vous alors que
pendant un an avec vos oeuvres
j'ai vécu avec vous alors avec lala vous
avez encore de deux réponses à faire
mais j'avais été bull a écouté nous
reste nous supplie qu'on coupe de jean
d'ormesson je peux pas laisser passer ça
j'ai jamais prétendu avoir été beaucoup
de gens dans la rue des gens comme jean
daniel jean d'ormesson vous avez
d'autres occasions de parler à la
télévision
alexandria au chili au portugal des gens
ont mené le même combat
oui ou non en france et j'adore une
salle de la farine colonialiste de
colonialisme en indochine socialisme et
le capitalisme
je parle aussi de ses membres et de 20
minutes
voyons vous le dira mais si vous venez
de dire quelques mots
voilà il a dit que des amis et moi je
prétends être plus proche sur certains
plans et pierre daix là dessus et non
pas du tout je vous ne soit pas retenue
pour ce junithi excusez moi je me suis
battue n'a pas manqué son enfance que le
faisait en carrosserie alexandre joly
arrêtez messieurs jean talon plus tôt
était possible de le plonger dans l'eau
président essayait de de plonger un
ballon dans l'ovni réussit pas le voilà
de nouveau la surface et oui le bal le
ballon reportait j'étais j'avais
vraiment eu du mal à vous calmer qu'est
ce que vous pensez vous demander votre
avis l'un et l'autre qui veut commencer
les deux on va vous envoyer ça jean
daniel moi je vais vous dire je souhaite
que ce soit pas prolongée parce que a
autant vous le dire je regrette ce que
je dis mais autant vous le dire aussi
je ne regrette pas ce que je lui ai fait
dire est ce que ce qu'il a dit
du fait de la question mal posée et dont
certains termes me gêne aujourd'hui ce
qu'il a répondu ensuite a été
essentielle pour son audience dans tous
les milieux dans lequel il avait suscité
un trouble
c'est pourquoi je suis en ce partage
je me suis gêné d'avoir posé ces
questions de cette manière je suis
heureux d'avoir grandi son image en
provoquant ses réponses jean d'ormesson
contrairement à jean daniel j'avais
complètement oublié l'incident et
j'avais raison de l'avoir oublié parce
que avoir raison est mauvais pour le
caractère avoir raison et mais je crois
qu'on ne peut pas comparer le chili élu
à sa part promis de bamako je me demande
pourquoi j'ai raison si vous voulez on
ne peut pas comparer pinochet et staline
non on ne peut pas et c'est la seule
chose que je dis bien merci à tous les
deux alors autre polémique à la fois
intellectuel et et pelé politique qui a
opposé cette fois mais à propos n'ont
pas l'urss mes propos de la chine
simon leys et maria antonieta match qui
simon leys au j'ose dire que dans ce
livre la forêt en feu il ya tout si
mauvaise passe que la première partie il
trouve le fin connaisseur et l'amoureux
de la culture chinoise et dans la
deuxième partie et le quai politique eh
bien on y trouve le pourfendeur des dd
il ironique des intellectuels français
notamment qui ont fait on fait le lit de
mao tsé toung un certain moment en
france mais s'est trouvé une situation
quand j'étais témoin j'avais la réalité
la réalité
féroce la réalité atroce de la terreur
maoïste devant les yeux le cadavre
dérivés au fil de l'eau il venait
hâtives sur les grèves de au cambodge
été
un homme s'est fait assassiner sur le
pas de ma porte parce qu'il s'était
moqué un peu de ma faute si ton à la
radio etc
on rencontre tous les jours les gardes
rouges qui avaient échappé à la
répression militaire dans les camarades
avaient été exécutés jeter vivants dans
des cages dans la rivière et ainsi de
suite
bref on avait sous les yeux l'immensité
et l'évidence de cette erreur atroce
représenter le maoïsme pour la chine et
au quotidien qu'est ce qu'on voyait mais
on voyait en europe des gens comme
madame macho qui est comme la presse
respectable et c'est qu'ils décrivaient
un univers de fantasy n'ayant absolument
aucune aucune relation avec ce que nous
avions sous les yeux prenons le cas de
madame bachelot qui par exemple je n'ai
rien contre 20 m qui personnellement je
n'ai jamais eu le plaisir de faire sa
connaissance
quand je parle macho qui je parle d'une
certaine idée de la chine je parle de
son oeuvre pas de sa personne son
ouvrage de la chine
c'est ce qu'on peut dire de plus
charitable c'est que c'est d'une
stupidité totale parce que si on
l'accusé pas d'être stupide vous dit que
c'est une escroquerie
comme le macho qui constatent avec
émerveillement que en chine
les ouvriers refusent les augmentations
de salaire et estime que des
organisations syndicales sont superflus
les paysans pratiquent la philosophie et
la pensée de mao c'est pousser les
cacahuètes mais je ne dis pas ça mais
vous l'écrivez madame
qu'est ce qu'il fait parce poussez vous
me donnez la page parce que non vous
devez être serré là vous devez dire ça
dans la page vous expliquer comment la
dialectique heureusement de la
production dans les centres a demandé
mon côté à ce moment là parce que j'ai
jamais connu ça vous utilisez vous des
babioles éthiquement vous soyez
j'en touchais de ça oui je vais vous
reprennent point dû répondre je paie pas
cet été c'est l'autre l'autre coin coin
fondamental encore c'est évidemment ce
mythe que le maoïsme
c'est au fond c'est la rupture avec le
stalinisme
voilà le maoïsme bon ça ça va à
l'encontre de toute évidence historique
connue de tout le monde
entre 50 et 52 en chine
les meilleurs spécialistes évaluent à
partir d' extrapolations fondées sur des
documents du parti communiste chinois
eux mêmes le nombre d'exécutions
politiques à 5 millions entre 50 et 52
cette information était parfaitement
disponibles vous auriez pu la consulter
avant d'aller en chine ça me semble à
peu près élémentaire le chapitre de la
chine d'un bel élan de bonheur traite de
mondanités parisiennes
il ya des petites galipettes sexuelle
des aventures ici il ya des salons
parisiens et c'est la chine disparaît de
l'horizon et on s'aperçoit simplement on
s'aperçoit simplement que la chine n'a
jamais été pour vous qu'un prétexte à
conversation à la mode dans les salons
parisiens et du jour où la mode est
passée la chine n'existe plus et un
milliard d'hommes bascule de l'autre
côté de l'horizon on en parle plus on
les voit plus on parle seulement de
monsieur sollers et d'autres personnages
oui alors alain peyrefitte philippe
sollers et jean françois revel
ce qui est vrai c'est que marié
antonetti un match qui l a pas eu de
chance parce que arrêté gamme courageux
parce qu'elle a quand même pris pour
tous les intellectuels occidentaux
notamment français qui se verrait été un
peu léger quand il parle de la chine qui
compteraient sa patte et six mois patty
et simon laisse effectivement était un
homme tout à fait indigne et alors
aujourd'hui quel est votre sentiment
seiler sentiment c'est qu'il faudrait
parler de la chine aujourd'hui au lieu
de faire cette rétrospective c'est à
dire que ce qui est curieux vrai nom ce
qui est curieux c'est qu'en effet la
chine art disparu aujourd'hui c'est à
dire que la répression et constance
qu'il ya des exécutions tous les jours
et que personne n'en parle et qu'il
faudrait demander alors à ça il faut
faire une émission là dessus et mais
avec simon l'aise avec la turquie avec
moi avec revel avec perfide qui nous
dira peut-être une réalité différente
passe puisqu'il a rencontré les
dirigeants chinois qui mène aujourd'hui
la répression et donc il ya des photos
qui paraissent en italie je ne sais pas
si elles sont parus en france mais vous
savez qu'on exécute les joueurs gs qui
l'ont même quotidien des affaires nominé
ce qu'à l'époque quand même vous étiez
pas les uns les autres je parle de bar
qui avait fait deux voiliers fait des
voyages à bas je n'ai pas été quand même
peut-être un peu léger non on pensait
pas léger je sais pas non c'était assez
d'un produit fabriqué pesant peut-être
mais pas léger alain peyrefitte
mais j'aurai un peu tendance à renvoyer
dos à dos macho qui saisit mauvaise
pourquoi macho qui évidemment elle
méritait une volée de bois vert elle
avait fait un seul voyage n'avait pas
fait de contre enquête à hong kong macao
et taïwan
elle n'avait pas écouter ceux qui
étaient d'un avis opposé
elle montrait qu'un côté des choses et
pas l'autre et donc elle mérite est
assez largement une mise en boîte mais
en ce qui concerne cimolai je trouve que
nous venons d'assister un assassinat on
ne traite pas une femme comme ça
d'abord et puis je dirais que je dirais
que simon leys et pêche
de la même manière mais en sens inverse
que macho qui qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
match ok l approche des ses fantasmes
sur la chine et ensuite de la chine tel
qu'elle l'avait vu sur le remplacer
d'une européocentrisme et que fait simon
leys dans ses livres il fait lui aussi
de l'europe et au centrisme cette année
qui projette l'occident les valeurs de
l'occident sur la chine à l'omc la chine
c'est d'autre choix donc pas sa réponse
est qu'il n'a pas forcé là il a forcé la
mecque là je trouve qu'il a un peu forcé
il a raison de l'aviron
les jours dire qu'il faut renvoyer dos à
dos soljenitsyne et staline je trouve ça
monstrueux en 1990 on peut se dire une
chose pareille
car enfin le grand phénomène c'est quand
même que pendant 20 ans l'occident ces
deux semaines et en bateau que nous
avions toutes les informations sur les
millions de morts
les dizaines et centaines de millions de
morts du grand bond en avant et de la
révolution culturelle et nous les hommes
et des dieux mais nous le sommes laissés
duper le fait est que nous pouvions
avoir toutes les informations que nous
les avions d'ailleurs que nous n'avons
pas voulu les voir le grand mystère
c'est la raison pour laquelle l'occident
a été véritablement s'est affaissé dans
un abîme de stupidité jusqu'au point
d'idolâtrer ce tissu de sornettes qui
s'appelait le petit livre rouge et le
grand problème c'est ça est-ce que nous
allons pouvoir tirer les enseignements
de cette crédibilité parce que quelque
chose d'autre va surgir dans l'avenir
qui n'aura pas le même visage ne parlera
pas le même langage n'aura pas le même
aspect même idéologie mais reconnaîtront
nous cette nouvelle source de tentations
et de dupuy un beau soleil il possible
alors dans quelques années on se dise
que la paix reste rock car à la classe
tos à cet exil dantesque opérations d
information à laquelle tous les médias
occidentaux
tous les intellectuels tout le monde
toutes les affaires auront participé à
la formation d un terme à ce que je
voudrais dire ce soir c'est très sain
informations c'est très simple il ya eu
sur la chine le vol devant tout le monde
à délirer c'est un beau coup genre de
moi je pense que je voudrais dire c'est
simplement parce qu'il faut passer une
information c'est que comme par hasard
la chine s'avère le quart de l'humanité
art disparu dans un trou noir parce que
oui
non parce qu'aujourd'hui le régime de la
rive-nord dit on aura droit à légion a
aujourd'hui bien à la pérestroïka à la
glace noces à l'euphorie démocratique
général et donc voilà je suis là pour
dire ça on nous ici mon live veut dire
la même chose au mac ce qui la même
chose
peyrefitte la même chose et vous la même
chose nous admettait aujourd'hui la
chine n'a pas droit à la démocratie au
fleury que nous célébrons on nous
explique toile à vous faire du commerce
avec un milliard de personnes sont
conviées
salle de tiananmen bon groupe c'est la
même c'est pas ça c'est le massacre tous
les jours tous les jours mais depuis
cela donc ce soir nous sommes d'accord
vous êtes d'accord aussi
non mais vous l'avez pas fait la
répression est atroce nous autres
occidentaux ne pourront pas supporter ça
mais il faut replacer ça dans une
personne n'y a pas d'efforts de la chine
certes il ya 90 de l'énergie il ya 4000
ans de rébellion noyer dans le sang non
médina is a lancé à lyon pouvait
gouverner a pris leurs arrières baby
parlons de ce qui s'est passé il ya 20
ans mais parlons pas de ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui alain peyrefitte on
dit alors commencé comme d'habitude mais
excusez moi mais quand on dit quand dont
il faut replacer sa lorsqu'une simple
lorsqu'on commence une phrase comme ça
on est prêts déjà excusé des choses dans
les boîtes où on les voit avec recul
maintenant on voit avec recul ces gens
sont accueillants les voit pas avec
recul qu'est-ce qui se passe eh bien on
oscille on va d'un extrême à l'autre
effet ce conte tout refait les européens
depuis trois siècles
concernant les affaires marchent très
bien les chinois le quart de l'humanité
ont disparu dans un trou noir et ils
n'ont pas droit à l'euphorie
démocratique général et aux droits de
l'homme planète
merci merci merci à tous les 3es alors
évidemment il ya des ruptures de ton
formidable dans cette émission vous
allez vous apercevoir la nouvelle
séquence est ce qui arrive
en effet nous allons revenir des choses
très terre à terre le sexe animales et
végétales les clients luisantes dont le
ver luisant
oui amusant oui la lune avec la ruse à
mon avis du nom là mais disent
précisément namibie vous allez vous ne
peut pas éteindre ses bras parce qu'ils
sont turquie et la méduse apprend à
vivre à deux tendrement secrètement sans
jamais se toucher
mais ça c'est l'enseignement 2012 c'est
l'amour l'amour proche mais l'amour
vierge tandis que le ver luisant
enseigne comment peut s'aimer en
s'illuminant c'est l'amour du maire
c'est l'enseignement où il suffit de
s'éclairer et on conjugue ses lumières
c'est l'enseignement du ver luisant
lafleur puisque nous sommes dans le
sujet ce soit la fleur c'est l'amour
parfait total c'est l'amour total est
parfait lorsque vous pencher sur une
rose pour la respirer vous n'avez jamais
pensé que vous étiez en train de
respirer
sexe vous aurez même 2,2 saxe qui sont
en train de faire l'amour
et dieu sait si ça sent bon ce poste qui
n'est pas le cas
toujours dans les eaux très bas et quand
vous vous êtes au printemps vous
rencontrez un arbre en fleurs tout à
coup ils exagèrent cerisiers et vous ne
vous rendez pas compte que cet arbre qui
est un million de fleurs est en train de
faire l'amour un million de fois je vais
regarder les cerisiers autrement il ya
des peuples qui font l'amour ensemble
via un petit singe le titille valoti
this has et c'est très amusant parce que
c'est très social justement là ça fait
très hlm quoi en fait c'est le titi titi
de colombie alors ce sont des petits
singes très sympathique très gentils
comme ça mais sauf qu'ils sont assez
comme souvent les petits singes
acariâtre et dès qu'ils s'installent
quelque part c'est des disputes avec les
voisins sans fins et des querelles qui
sont très monogame au départ ça que ya
le petit titi et ça madame titi et lors
si jamais il ya une dame titi qui vient
c'est une scène sans fin c'est vraiment
des gens qui s'engagent tout le temps
puis arrive la saison des amours et
alors là ça devient une sorte de partout
où tous les petits mais vraiment les
dames petite île sans savoir qui est le
mari de la dame qui tique frère d'un
petit i qui est le cousin d'un petit
tout le monde se fait titiller
et ça dure un certain temps et après
c'est terminé c'est terminé ça c'est
très humain afin très humain voilà
c'était jean françois gosselin qui va
répondre dans la deuxième bouquet
bouquet la gentillesse était cette
métaphore bouquet de de réponse à la
question quel est le mot de la langue
française que vous préférez alors
jean-françois jocelyn vous ça tombe bien
parce que je voulais dire rêver mais pas
dans le genre chic me dire on croit
rêver
non seulement causé titi mais même avec
ce qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure oui
rêver rêver
patrick grainville mois frénésie parce
que j'aime lic c'est parce que j'aime
l'excès alors là on est on est au milieu
des des prix goncourt dans une série de
prix goncourt tahar benjelloun moi c'est
le mot dignité parce qu'il a tendance à
l'oublier un peu et puis parce qu'il est
aussi beau que trois notes de
duke ellington erik orsenna oui plume
parce que ça sert à voler et à écrire
mais à wimbedon raymond devos n'est pas
le prix goncourt pas encore non ça va
venir et je ne désespère pas oui john ne
désespère pas alors on vous oui non rien
du tout et où la langue d'un mauvais jeu
j'aimerais bien votre mot on vous
entendra mieux tout à l'heure vous nous
parler la langue de bois où il est mais
là je serai quand même votre mot écouter
aujourd'hui oui libyen de sa chance ou
les jouets
mais aujourd'hui ces rivières parce que
ça coule de source mais c'est très
gênant c'est très joli
alors je me tourne avec la gauche
djibrine i mais moi c'est une expression
je me suis aperçu que des employés
souvent sans savoir exactement ce
qu'elle voulait dire c'est au fur et à
mesure
à cause d'eux au fur et à mesure alors
c'est notre décorateur michel millecamps
qui inscrit sur les portes du studio
mais sur la double paire de sio tous les
mots que vous voulez 80 écrivains auront
choisi alors maintenant le mot de
christian julie celi ce serait vif parce
que ces trois lettres pour un mot ça
suffit c'est très bien et c'est vif et
sedif
le rgi alphonse boudard rire brillante
et souvent avoir en pleurer rires oui
yves jégu je dirais grande mer en
souvenir de marie stopes qui a écrit il
ya si longtemps que la grammaire était
le pivot des vrais équilibres politiques
ah ah ah non je ne connaissais pas celle
là
bien qu'il y ait eu pas mal de
d'engueulades apostrophes mais henry
général d'ailleurs vous les avez vu tout
à l'heure on avait assisté à une elles
sont généralement brève assez rapide
assez vive
alors voici de nature très différente 3
engueulades à apostrophes
j'ai appris par exemple que votre
première ambition votre premier ta
langue c'était la peinture ça j'étais
très très surpris à quel âge 28 ans mais
mascella sais pas quel était le genre de
peinture que faisait gainsbourg et donc
de dessin j'étais figuratif
je peux sur cubisme je n'y ai fait je
suis passé ça s'appelle une initiation
un art majeur devant l'initiation par un
art mineur comme ce que nicolas
l'économie que nous faisons nous mais
qu'elle est là pour le surréalisme qui
vous avez relevé lors une chanson mais
c'est aussi l'image en remerciement
mekhissi à leurs abonnés a annoncé béart
qui te parle
oui mais j'ai bien en quoi est ce que
ces mineurs oui c'est clair
ces milliards se situera que la peinture
il n'a pas besoin d'initiation mais
toujours la chanson qu'a besoin des
initiations pour la peine pour les arts
majeurs une architecture la peinture et
la musique classique et la littérature
et la poésie architecture qui initie
quand il ya peu ici s'il te plaît et de
la santé initiée dès ne faisant pas de
la poésie
non il n'y a pas d'armé mais ce n'est
pas la peine de faire de la chanson dans
ces mineurs sinon je ne serais pas là tu
peux tout est important même la cuisine
si tu prends du pognon serge gainsbourg
toutes vos chansons considérer que ce
sont des choses mineures alors c'est
vrai le super on vous dit
en politique être femme est devenue un
argument publicitaire est un avantage
réel mais c'est ce qu'on est en train de
voir
mais monsieur merci fragile
on est entraîneur on est en train de
voir ces femmes fragiles vraiment à
protéger écoutez je ne prétends pas
avoir 48 % du temps ici de parole bien
qui est de 48 voulons c'est vrai encore
je sais moi écouter c'est moi dire ce
que j'ai à dire on ne fait que parler
écrié gesticuler vous faites des scènes
de ménages
alors je dis que oui effectivement être
femme et un avantage à l'heure actuelle
du mythique parce que ni ne suffit pas à
huriel m il ne suffit pas de dire il ya
très peu de femmes quand il a débuté
tout ça mais si elles ne veulent pas là
qu'est ce que vous voulez non mais non
jeunes ou laissez moi parler je vous en
prie je n'osais pas interrompu tout à
l'heure bien que vous ayez par les cas
soir mais c'est parce que je suis en
salle et ça na pas leur plaisir à vous
de lui vraiment nous sommes sur le banc
des accusés je produise alors que vous
permet de vous permettez vous avez c'est
vrai laisse-le parler de ce que je vous
ai laissé sans jamais faire de défense
voilà les quatre juges et ça fait des
siècles que ça dure
ils ont mis en accusation molière c'est
très facile de rire vous arrêtez pas de
rire dans votre métier
nous nous produisons ça s'est passé
vraiment non mais les précieuses
ridicules c'est luigi donnerait très
bien vous allez voir ça
depuis quatre siècles vous êtes les
juges et nous écrivons les livres dont
vous vivez
parce que vous êtes vous vivez de ce
métier de nous critiquer c'est sûr
ah oui alors vous êtes vous manger à
tous les râteliers
vous êtes vous j'ai un métier
ah non non et non celui des filles il va
aux critiques
est ce que vous êtes créateur je n'ose
même pas dire que je suis écrivain parce
que moi je trouve pas si tout ça c'est
très facile à faire
alors que je prouve à la parole je
voudrais bien dire s'il voulait
constater notre humilité
elle s'est défendue lui a dit excusez
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas eu j'ai pas pu
faire d'études l'uad excusez moi je
vends des lits je veux dire dans trois 3
même chose d'excusés nous messieurs les
juges bon attendez mais si c'est ce qui
c'est là les noms des audits les
téléspectateurs viennent me voir
n'oubliez pas que vous êtes des acteurs
ils viennent de vous voir tous les
quatre
et là chez les messieurs bertrand
poirot-delpech qui était encore que les
tipis terre il ya quelques mois et qui
est lui même écrivain françois
nourissier qui est écrivain et critique
littéraire et roger brini qui
participait à cette aimable conversation
festival du livre ii bis qui est lui
même aussi critique littéraire à france
culture et et écrivain romancier
alors qu'est-ce que moi mais je respecte
oui non mais il ya eu beaucoup d'amants
peut pas tous passer un bel été et quand
même c'était quand même assez assez rude
à c'était bien c'était assez rude
c'était bien mais j'adorais surtout
quand jacques robert c'est comparer un
molière mais alors bon ce nom mais ce
qui est vrai c'est quand même il ya
toujours eu cette bataille entre ceux
qui produisent les les écrivains et ceux
qui critiquent et qu'on appelle
d'ailleurs des critiques
alors comment vous tous les trois vous
êtes des deux côtés de la barrique et
alors comment faites vous comment
faites-vous pour dépôt pour pouvoir
ne jamais entrer dans une querelle
partisane d'un côté comme de l'autre
tech et constate hélas aujourd'hui sur
le plateau et dans les extraits que
finalement les écrivains sont très
mauvais des batteurs ils savent pas très
bien se battre parce que c'était quelque
fois on avait l'impression vous le
regrettiez certains soirs et parce qu'au
fond ils ont l'esprit d'escalier et qui
ne trouvent pas les arguments tout de
suite un écrivain un écrivain écrit
parce qu'il sait pas parler souvent
parce qu'il faut se battre dans
l'immédiat et donc souvent les batailles
étaient assez navrante
elles nous font sourire aujourd'hui mais
finalement moi elle me craignent
certaine gêne en tout cas je suis un peu
de la vie de godard est jules renard
c'est qu'un critique qui un critique
c'est un peu un soldat qui tire sur le
régiment et pour ça je me suis toujours
gardé de faire des événements et je
préfèrerais parler des livres que j'aime
on a si peu de place je préfère être
parler des livres que j'aime plutôt de
tirer dans les coins ce qui m'intéresse
pas mais est ce que vous n'avez pas dire
la même chose françois nourissier c'est
à dire qu'on parle de c'est pas moi je
parle d'environ 50 52 livres par an il
en paraît des milliers donc pourquoi
aller choisir dans ces milliers de
livres ceux sur lesquels on va pouvoir
faire un carton pourquoi se tailler un
petit peu de gloriole dans la peau d'un
autre écrivain ça c'est un certain c'est
que j'ai jamais compris cet amusant
d'écrire à nérac mentionnant sade en
bourse et faciles à se passer en ans
vous écrivez un article le féroce
pendant une semaine dans paris les gens
vous dire sur le trottoir formidable
tant papier vous vous donnez un mal de
chien pendant des heures pour faire
aimer un livre un peu difficile personne
a même lu jusqu'au bout la chronique
sans le centre avec les lecteurs sont à
l'affût de raison de ne pas lire pacs ne
faut pas le faut pas leur en fournir ces
mêmes idées alors là je me rappelle je
me rappelle quand même alors par roger
prix ni sur france culture des
éreintement alors ça je me rappelle très
bien je m'en souviens très bien
oui je veux dire que moi je veux bien
être un dispensateur d'amour et je veux
dire que tout de même de temps en temps
pour établir la vérité je veux dire que
des gens qui passent pour des écrivains
qui n'en sont pas des gens qui sont
célébrés qui n'en valent pas la peine de
30 ans ça vaut tout de même la peine une
colle dire je trouve pas ce que je
comprends très bien ce que vient de dire
baudet de pêche et françois nourissier
c'est vrai que c'est pas beaucoup de
place pour parler des livres alors
autant parler des livres qu'on aime moi
quand je reçois des des écrivains dans
mon émission
c'est comme quand on reçoit des gens a
dit mais on n'a pas envie de le renvoyer
le potage à la figure tout de même on
les reçoit c'est pas pour les engueuler
mais tout de même de temps en temps il y
a des ddv des petits disons des premiers
rôles que l'on fait venir si on leur dit
pas ce que l'on pense de leur livre
alors où est la villa dedans où est la
vérité
il faut de la vérité de temps en temps
dans dans la vie même dans la vie
littéraire et c'est ça qu'il ya de plus
difficile la meilleure il ya aussi il ya
aussi le silence qui est larmes la plus
féroce ne pas ne pas parler d'un livre
c'est la façon la plus nette la plus la
plus pointue
oui de de lui faire du mal chacun y
pense il s'agit pas servir la soupe mais
on peut très souvent se taire ça on en
profite ouais maintenant je ne suis plus
critiques moi j'ajouterai une chose
c'est que dans sur ce plateau
il ya quand même une pléiade de gens je
suis désolé mais s'ils avaient une boum
qui tombe dans ce studio
[ __ ] s'offre un appel d'air des jeux
ne se réjouirait mais je trouve qu'on y
perdrait sacrément je trouve je suis
ébahi je trouve bien il ya là une
pléiade de talents je le dis pas pour
faire l'amour à qui que ce soit je
trouve que moi je suis passé par la
réunion de talents qui est ici eh bien
je suis épaté aussi par le boulot de
pivot parce qu'il est fait aussi pendant
15 ans et je peux vous dire qu'on ira
pas d'éloges deux livres par jour
c'est merveilleux et c'est fort bidasses
alors c'était des romanciers que vous
aimiez lire et que vous auriez que vous
aurez certainement plaisir à voir et
entendre de nouveau même brièvement dans
l'ordre maurice genevoix gilbert cesbron
georges perec et jean louis borie et
bien mes premières lectures je parle des
lectures des brandes est très grand bon
on était chez moi prématuré et j'ai
plongé à pieds jouent enfin j'ai sauté
dans balzac dans l'ue go dans ce radar
mentalist oeil non et c'est un méga
henry sa fin c'était suffocant pour moi
est décourageant on ne peut pas quand on
a 15 ans même si on a la velléité
d'écrire on en est aux petites cousines
au vert alexandre un de ses élèves on
trouvait retour y ait du soleil enfin
des trucs comme ça oui pourquoi mais
bien sûr la fosse poésie qui simplement
des petits soubresauts de puberté et
puis c'est tout mais écrire c'est autre
chose
et alors à ce moment là ça a été de
nature à me décourager
et c'est le besoin de témoigner de
perpétuer des événements qui étaient
dignes pour moi qui ne devait pas être
oubliée justement à cause de la
souffrance bon pour en finir avec l
impro finir détour d'une génération
sacrifiée
j'ai plusieurs réputation je peux pas me
défaire sa nos merdes heures c'est pas
vrai mes livres sont pas ennuyeux il
polit sont graves mais sont pas lieu je
suis un moraliste
c'est absolument faux jeu est la morale
pour moi le christianisme est tout sauf
de la morale comprenait alors je pense
je passe sur écrivain catholique sur
témoin de son temps sur écrivait engager
enfin toutes les statistiques on est
allé dans le dos vous êtes chrétien
quand même ah non oui je suis un
chrétien qui écrit des livres
si j'étais marxisme écrit aussi des
livres et on sentirait entre les lignes
que le marxiste du moins je l'espère
ou alors ce serait un faux jeton il ya
d'ailleurs quelqu'un qui fait des pauses
dans votre livre mais au fond ce vous
êtes vous-même faiseurs de potes parce
que vous reconstituer le puzzle de
toutes les vies de toutes les
géographies de tous les objets et de
toutes les photographies de tous les
livres qui sont passés dans cet immeuble
sg c'est d'envisager ce livre comme com
entre le entre le lecteur et moi c'est à
dire je pense que ce qui est extrêmement
important c'est de laisser au lecteur la
liberté dans un livre que le livre soit
quelque chose d'ouvert et pas de fermer
pas de fermer autour d'un vin d'un thème
d'une idée ou d'un grand de grands mots
d'un grand axe mais qu' il puisse à
l'intérieur du livre respirer peut-être
voulait-il dire tout de suite de
rappeler qu est ce que ça veut dire
c'est l'expression c'est le pied après
ça c'est du langage sainement et
fortement populaire le pied qui est une
partie de l'être humain comme vous savez
représente le bonheur d'être et
lorsqu'on voulait prendre son pied
cela veut dire très exactement avoir un
plaisir tel que l'on appelle ça la
jouissance
si j'ai bien compris la couverture de
votre lit vous avez remplacé la rose au
poing par myosotis au pied le myosotis
au pied je ne dis absolument à ce que ça
soit complémentaire parce que je
voudrais qu au terme de ce livre exemple
le droit à l'humour sont inscrits au
programme commun j'espère y arriver
je voudrais que les landes maquis
chantre des lendemains qui se marrent
semaines qui viennent on va reprendre le
programme commun ben justement ailleurs
jugé une correspondance extrêmement
sérieux et serré avec georges marchais
oui on s'envoie des poulets qui se
penche pas qu'on croyait et je vais tiff
absolument georges jojo parce que de
graines intimité très poussée je suis
absolument pour que le droit à l'humour
soit parmi les droits du citoyen dans
l'arc en ciel des libertés dont le parti
communiste fort en ce moment le
l'éventail de dieu que je veux que le
droit à la rigolade sont inscrits dans
les textes est maintenant troisième
salve ou bouquets de mots choisis par
les écrivains gélas au premier famille
angers deux écrivains
ministre alain decaux ministre de la
francophonie quel est votre l'autre mon
préféré et bien c'est le mot x ou y
c'est le troisième set droite c'est le
mot foi et folie lorsque j'ai besoin le
croire mais c'est aussi le mot fois fo
yes lorsqu'on dit il était une fois et
peut-être le mot fois il faut il la
ville doit se voir à quelques fois dans
la vie mais je n'y avais pas pensé votre
la troisième au retrait et puis jorge
semprun qui est on le sait milices de la
culture du gouvernement espagnol de
felipe gonzalez
deux mots résidents privilégier ce qui
était écrit sur ma carte de séjour en
france je trouve que tu outillés sur le
plan administratif métaphysique reste de
fait vous êtes cernés par l'académie
française jorge semprun qui est
peut-être peut-on sait-on jamais une
indication sur votre avenir
jean dutourd eh bien je crois qu'il n'y
a qu'un seul mot enfin le plus beau mot
de la langue française pour un écrivain
français tout au moins depuis 15 ans
c'est le mot pivot oui mais écoutez je
ne peux vraiment pas je ne peux vraiment
pas être accusé de vous lécher les pieds
puisque vous vous en allez je peux au
contraire le dire maintenant dans un
pays avec une minuscule fait avec une
minuscule 1 va naturellement d'accord et
puis d'ici à mars au mais moi je pense
notre passé le à du tout non pas celle
d'abord oui moi je pensais que vous
alliez me répondait pas tant épatant ben
vous le mot épatant vous en fait un
usage modéré on prend plutôt épatant
plutôt un vous préférez oui pas tant si
vous voulez mais moi j'avais mon idée
oui bon les mettais pas tant et les
niveaux pour du tout marceau eh bien je
dirais liberté d'abord parce que le moc
aide à vivre et ensuite parce que je
trouve qu'il est très bien écrit avec 7
lb et et qui sent comme trois colonnes
et les deux voyelles et aehi qui sont la
gaieté même
henri troyat pour moi ce serait le mot
tolérance d'abord parce que je trouve
qu'il sonne agréablement à l'oreille et
ensuite parce qu'il désigne une qualité
rare chez l'homme la faculté de se
mettre à la place des autres de
comprendre leurs problèmes
et après tout c'est exactement l'opposé
du fanatisme c'est pour ça que j'aime ce
mot jacques laurent
ben moi ce sera à remanier le verbe
harmonier que je préfère beaucoup à
harmoniser parce qu'il est plus
harmonieux qu'harmoniser et puis aussi
parce qu'ils ne figurent plus dans les
dictionnaires ya que dans le litre est
qu'on peut le trouver et quand je
l'envoie dans un livre je suis obligé
dans la marge de dire je dis bien
harmonier sens en moi je t'aime s alors
comme on l'écrivait vous quand même tant
qu'à faire h arm onisr très bien jean
d'ormesson est bien dans ce genre de
débat il ya un mot que j'aime beaucoup
c'est le mot silence
[Musique]
c'est alors là vraiment bon bertrand je
ferai pas de commentaires je resterai
silencieux
bertrand poirot-delpech je choisirais le
mot viste en boire parce qu'il ne veut
rien dire
le moa vous voulez vous la péter parce
que michel millecamps dois l'écrire vis
ta vie ce temps boire le liberté de
chacun dans ce cri comme on veut et ça
ne veut rien dire donc tout dire très
bien alain peyrefitte
j'en veux un peu à mon ami félicien
marceau qui m'a coupé l'herbe sous le
pied aux pour peut dire deux fois le
même mot un bon alors ça fait un mot qui
auraient été pendant ces deux fois
liberté je trouve que il résume toutes
les valeurs
et qu'il s'agisse de la liberté de
l'écrivain du créateur de liberté du
citoyen se dire la démocratie la liberté
du pays c'est-à-dire l'indépendance la
liberté des échanges c'est à dire
économie enfin la liberté tout est dans
la liberté la liberté est un des
derniers apparu académie française
michel serres parce que la voyelle est
caractéristique de langue française
j'ai choisi le mot ensemencement
l'action d'ensemencer et pour d'autres
raisons philosophiques aussi pour des
raisons pédagogiques et amoureuse merci
alors il est toujours amusant
intéressant émouvant de revoir leur
première apparition à apostrophes dans
l'ordre jmg le clézio bernard henri lévy
et patrick modiano et s'il ya un mot qui
revient très souvent sous votre plume
c'est le mot silence
oui parce que je crois que c'est une des
vertus fondamentales de l'homme de
pouvoir justement de pouvoir terre en
lui tout ce qui nuirait à la beauté du
monde extérieur
il a cette possibilité de devenir
silencieux 2
ressembler aux paysages qu'il aime
seulement encore faut-il que ce paysage
c'est difficile à trouver ce genre de
paysage aujourd'hui
oui enfin ce n'est pas vraiment
difficile mais c'est difficile d'y vivre
parce que la société urbaine dont on
parlait société de la civilisation
justement vous impose cette cette
habitude du bruit il faut faire du bruit
il faut faire du bruit et faire entendre
du bruit c'est à dire faire partie du
cycle du bruit consommer et donner du
mou y
mais est-ce que vous même vous n'êtes
pas tenté par cette évasion vers le
silence et l'immobilité
oui c'est contradictoire parce que
j'écris et faire c'est aussi faire du
bruit évidemment même les mots écrits
sur du papier font du bruit alors il ya
cette contradiction c'est un fait mais
je crois que il ya une possibilité même
à travers les mots ou d'arrivée je
dirais presque à exprimer ce qu'ils
rentrent les mots c'est à dire exprimer
ce que les mots ne dispose il me semble
que l'essentiel de la littérature
enfin ce que j'aime dans la littérature
c'est ce qu'elle dit en dehors des mots
à côté des mosquées le laisse entendre
à côté des mots qui comprennent
cylindres une science ça s'entend bien
sur et s'est montré comment le
socialiste est malheureusement une des
formes possibles et peut-être pour nous
aujourd'hui la plus contemporaine des
formes de barbarie
ce que l'on essayé de montrer c'est
comment l'optimiser l'historique que
j'attaque effectivement dans le livre
est toujours fondée sur l'idée qu'il y
as avant le pouvoir qu'il ya avant le
maître qui vient avant le malheur une
espèce de bonnes natures qui existaient
préalablement un âge d'or et qu' il
faudrait retrouver un j'essaie de
montrer comment les révolutionnaires les
progressistes les socialistes en général
ont toujours été obsédé par l'idée
qu'avant la avant le malheur avant la
fatalité il y avait une espèce de rosé
comme sa matinale qu'on pouvait faire
advenir qu'on pouvait faire
on pouvait faire arriver avec le au
forceps de la révolution pour celle de
libération donc j'ai essayé de montrer
aux rites et comment cette cette idée
d'un bon état de nature cette idée d'une
nature en général est une fausse idée
que c'est un leurre bon c'est alors qu'
effectivement fait vivre et c'est un
leurre qui parfois aussi et c'est
l'autre thèse du livre peut également
faire mourir les bars à vous écouter
patego non mais pourquoi ils font oui
mais à ce qu est ce que vous pensez que
pour vous pour votre fille qui a quel
âge maintenant elle a 2 ans 3 ans de 200
est ce que c'est beau c'est une chance
pour elle d'avoir donc un livret de
famille d'avoir une fille l'état civil
en bonne et due forme à tous aucune
importance c'est à dire elle s'en fiche
complètement
c'est des choses qui avaient de
l'importance pour moi mais pour vous ça
l'important
oui parce que j'étais toujours axé sur
le passé ou sur ce qui avait précédé la
naissance ou des choses comme ça mais je
pense que le heureusement disposera pas
de ceux comme la plupart des enfants se
posera patients et la plupart des
personnages qui traversent votre ouvrage
sont justement des personnages qui
cherchent leurs racines
oui c'est un peu des personnages qui me
ressemblent comme des espèces de comme
dans les glaces ouyahia degré superposés
il ya une enfilade de verser leur
finalement votre vraie vos vraies
racines est ce que ne sont pas
finalement dans le dans la vie et dans
la langue française au oui parce que
finalement finalement les racines c'est
loin de la langue qu'on parle et puis
essayer d'écrire une autre très clair
pour vous rendre les choses un peu plus
créé les choses un peu biscornue iran
nucléaire c'est pour ça que le france
français qui a des vertus clarté et de
simplicité
g comptant ce tout le côté fluke je
ressens voilà alors malheureusement
j'espérais bien avoir patrick modiano
sur ce plateau et puis s'est décommandé
deux heures avant l'émission je regrette
bien parce que je les aime beaucoup et
bien henri lévy vous vous êtes
rosetti jamais revu c'est votre première
mission la post rock c'était pour la
barbarie à visage humain et l or comment
quelle impression ça vous fait pour voir
écouter d'abord cesser la première fois
je me vois apostrophe si j'ose dire donc
ça fait un drôle d'effet oui je ne sais
pas d'où l'impression bizarre mais
est-ce que alors votre célèbre chemise
blanche serait largement décolletée
est-ce que c'était à cette émission dont
77 est ce que c'était programmé avait
joué je crois pas je crois que c'est
vraiment un accident je crois qu'il
faisait très chaud ce jour là sur le
plateau et que probablement dans le feu
de la discussion il y avait une
polémique également très très vives y
avait en face de nous deux et c'est ici
la plaie au bras les leurs il y avait
maurice clavel qui étaient là et
d'ailleurs et que nous reverrons tout à
l'heure dans un moment bien parce que je
voulais dire que revoir cette émission
me fait aussi penser avec l'aval d'un
petit nicolas et oui moi il me semble
que dans la chaleur et de la salle et du
plateau et de la discussion ont en effet
probablement qu'un bouton de lâche
thomas schmidheiny sonné mais c'était
sûrement porte le meyboom n'est
aujourd'hui pas très chaud là bas les
fermes et regarder nord vous l'avez
reboutonner pendant qu'ils veulent l
extrait passé je vous ai vu que
machinalement erik orsenna
malheureusement l'émission où vous êtes
venus pour la première fois parce que
contrairement à ce que des gens dit il
pense que je vous invitais pour la
première fois seulement comme le plus le
prix goncourt ce n'est pas vrai vous
étiez venu avant pour la vie comme à
lausanne et même pour un autre livre
et malheureusement c'est l'une des
émissions d' apostrophes qui ont disparu
de l'ina les volets alors je sais pas si
c'est vous quelqu'un d'autre à duke à
vous le dire vous niez de plus vous ne
vous n'êtes plus est ce que est ce que
vous vous rappelez ce qui s'est passé
c'est une émission qui s'appelait à vous
écrivez et vous veniez chez les
écrivains et moi j'habitais au cinquième
étage donc c'était c'était long de
monter moi je mourrai de traquer vous
étiez souffler c'est à dire que l'élu a
été un peu tendu
oui voilà alors on a parlé de tas de
choses on
je me souviens notamment de football oui
voilà absolument c'est ma vie donner un
pronostic et le pronostic s'est révélé
exact après si fait que plein de gens à
acheter le roman parce qu'ils pensaient
qu'il y avait des recettes de pronostic
et puis non mais surtout après c'était
drôle parce que toute l'équipe est
redescendu donc les cinq étages et après
tout les gens sont sortis sur le palier
et on dit ce formidable écrivait des
livres ça va pas vous étiez intelligent
et c'est la pire façon une petite reine
dans la cour et bon c'était le soyons
francs pas loin du bonheur georges lui
ben quoi est-ce que imaginer ce que vous
avez imaginé george sand venant à la
télévision comment ce serait telle qu'on
portait mal parce qu'elle est un oui
n'aimait pas parler en public
tu as certainement on a fait d'elle une
48 une personne qui haranguait la foule
d'une fenêtre de sais plus quelle rumeur
et ce n'est pas vrai et est absolument
incapable de parler un peu plus elle
préférait la solitude pour accueillir
penser qu'elle pourrait refuser une
habitation je le suppose telle que je la
connais je la connais bien
vous avez l'impression les à connaît
depuis 40 ans bien oui oui oui c'est une
déception pour 21 millions très mal au
cou de vous dire ça alors nous allons on
va revoir notre extraits d'émissions
avec une médiane au sollers et puis on
aperçoit aussi jacques lanzmann alors il
faut dire maintenant écouter les
spectateurs comme en effet ce roman
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de chapitre
il n'y a pas de paragraphe il n'y a pas
de ponctuation il s'agit donc que d'une
seule phrase qui va la page une à la
page 250 de joie évidemment vous
expliquer pourquoi
pour lire dont il ya une ponctuation je
crois mais elle est intériorisée c'est à
dire qu'elle est dans le cours du style
lui même si j'avais dû employer les
points et les virgules les points
d'exclamation les points de suspension
serait pas été suffisant donc ce n'est
pas seulement une phrase etc sont des
milliers de phrases on est à l'intérieur
d'un flou qui ponctue ses phrases ou les
bannir un petit passage
qu'est ce que vous voulez au hasard
te dessin mamour beaucoup page 159 160
dans le haut et bien par exemple si on
les baises elles sont assommante
si on ne baisse pas elles sont
mécontentes presque jamais de souplesse
de délicatesse ou c'est trop me mets
aussi rien glace et d'où vient leur
légende sensibilité pourquoi ce silence
sur leur dureté leur boucle et en sort
horrifié si elle devait et éduquer les
types dans un sens ou athées ça se
saurait depuis le temps que ça c'est
multi adrar ici ou là fille qui sait
bien suisse et les adresses web diano
c'est curieux parce que euh je trouve
que ce livre correspond plus la
sensibilité de la fin des années 50
et c'est ça qui fait le charme et c'est
que en lisant on pense aux premières
chansons de ce h à 17 h à acheter celui
des visas classe par la police en ces
lendemains qui dit le vice est ce que ça
vous rappelle de bons souvenirs oui
c'était chan c'était charbon sale et
c'est vrai que bon c'était votre période
vous mettiez pas de population
oui c'est vrai que c'est un peu une bon
vous avez abandonné cette manière en jeu
je refais chatte ans encore en fait ça
ça c'est en train mais dans votre revue
paris may papa dans vos livres je peux
leur faire éventuellement ça me gêne pas
oui non mais j ai maintenant mes vous
expliquer très bien le lever pour
pourquoi les années 50
ce que vous voyez là dit les années 50
me diallo personne n'a fait ça dans les
années 50 mais enfin ça on peut faire ça
éternellement et le fait d'abandonner la
ponctuation d'aller vite dans la
formulation beckett a fait sa job il
s'affaissa bon c'est une forme de
rapidité dans l'écriture oui d'envoi on
peut leur faire tout autre chose aussi
il extrait que vous avez lu d'ailleurs
permis n'est pas mal non qui était très
belle et très bien m'a fait chausser
langmann qui vous a poussé à lire des
extraits mais qui avait dû qu'il peut
donner quelques ce qu'il s'est passé
aujourd'hui non ça doit pas donner plus
de dents mon avis aura pas le coup de
fil de protestation sauf si je dis alors
il ya de personne mais à l'époque alors
ça fait là bas c'est assez
vide en voilà et bien on a peut-être lui
invité en mai tester sacha distel pour
savoir si vibrant son cv seront ainsi
invités bon alors voici maintenant pour
montaillou village occitan gros succès
inattendu de librairie le premier
passage apostrophe d'emmanuel le roy
ladurie lyon lui j'ai l'impression
excusez moi monsieur le professeur
plages de france que vous avez couché
toutes les femmes de mon pays et c'est
franchement alors qu'elle est comment ce
miracle il pu s'opérer
et bien grâce à un échec c'est jacques
fournier l'évêque de pamiers
ce n'est pas bien de dire oui vincent
delory qui est une espèce de deux super
flics enfin deux de mes greider que le
poire au vin ce qui nous lie romans
policiers connaissent et qui a vraiment
tout retourné dans ce village pendant
cinq ou six ans en interrogeant une
trentaine d'habitants de façon peut-être
les at il un peu torturé mais je ne
crois pas trop quand même
mais il a interrogé avec beaucoup
d'intelligence et absolument sur tous
les aspects de leur vie sur leur
dialogue sur leur amour sur leur vie
matérielle sur leur sentiment sur leur
raison de vivre sur la religion
ces gens étaient hérétiques cathares
comment 10 comme en dira plus tard et et
puis il a faim il avait un secrétariat
incroyable d'une quinzaine de personnes
meilleures caves ou presque aussi bon
qu'à magnétophone actuelle oui tout ça
donc travées de l'occitan qui était la
langue locale en latin mais sur après
plusieurs copia sur un manuscrit et qui
a fini par atterrir à avignon où cet
évêque deviendra pape sous le nom de
benoît xii et à rome où
ou c'est resté à bibliothèque vaticane
et monsieur jean duvernoy à qui je rends
hommage érudits de toulouse de la
tyrrell a publié dans une édition parue
à toulouse en 1965 en lattes 3 volumes
de 15 cents pages voilà emmanuel le roy
ladurie et donc c'était montaillou
village occitan qui est devenu alors une
manière inattendue c'est un énorme
succès de librairie
le lendemain d'ailleurs de cette
émission il y avait un grand article de
ces deux clavel oui car j'avais eu un
dialogue avec elias et clavel qui était
maquisards avec mon père et que j'aurais
aimé revoir je n'ai pratiquement jamais
revu avait rendu hommage à ce dialogue
alors je vous ai invité plusieurs fois
mais quatre ans à peu près je vous avais
invité pour le carnaval de roman et je
me rappelle très bien vous avoir dit
écoutez moi j'avais bien aimé le
montaillou village occitan carnaval de
romance est illisible
j'ai trouvé que c'était illisible gelé
dit à l'antenne le lendemain les
libraires envoyait le livre à l'éditeur
il me suis demandé si vous en aviez
beaucoup voulu vous savez le roi de
france par bob les injures de dr dre et
non je crois que
l'un des hommes que j'admire le plus 7
ans rick est qu'ils n'étaient pas
vindicatif qui pratiquait le pardon non
pas des injures car ce n'était pas une
mais j'étais que je pouvais trouver
injuste mais je ne me suis demandé si
d'une certaine manière je ne vous avais
pas servi parce que en vous faisant une
sorte de virginité au collège de france
ou vos collègues n'aime pas beaucoup les
best-sellers c'est évident oui je suis
beaucoup de mal à nous enlever deux
spéciales r je ne sais pas donc donc
c'était tout c'était de très bon
finalement pour vous ensuite d'avoir une
succession d'échecs de livres qui ne se
vendait pas bien c'était très bon c'est
bien vu au collège de france
oui ce jour-là que le carnaval de romans
je vous y aider bon vous allez me donner
des nouvelles du
de l'argent qui a été collecté l'autre
jour par maître poulain à paris bape
lors de la vente aux enchères du décor
et du mobilier d' apostrophes donc on
avait recueilli combien 50 cent soixante
mille cinq cent soixante mille francs
alors que c'est l'argent a été remis à
l'association des amis de la
bibliothèque nationale
oui c'est monsieur el banna le président
et financier amis de la bibliothèque
nationale et nous venons d'acheter avec
ça l'ensemble des manuscrits de boris
vian que la veuve de boris vian nous a
va donc de remettre ces légumes des jeux
l'automne à pékin
j'irai cracher sur vos tombes qu'on peut
aimer au moins aimé les saints sonné et
la première version de l'airbus
ben voilà donc le décor a besoin des
éléments derrière ça donc produit de
l'argent et cet argent
donc j'ai servi à acheter les manuscrits
de boris vian et alors ce c'est le même
michel mille corps dont on a vendu le
décolletage à paribas qui a fait ce
somptueux décors exceptionnellement pour
cette dernière d' apostrophes i will i
am i 5642 livre il ya 5642 livre c'est à
dire autant de jours qu'il y a eu depuis
le premier numéro d' apostrophes
autrement dit un livre par jour je
voudrais qu'on applaudisse michel
millecamps pour
les émissions d' apostrophes étaient
souvent très très gai très très enjoué
on y a même chanté tout le plateau
chantait et vous allez l'entendre même
et surtout henri vincenot c'est julia
sont bel et bien en chante chez nous à
toutes les occasions pour l'alliance
pour la batteuse au port pour les
boudins le yodel la halle à yuya cépages
de la la chanson typique c'est le turbo
tutu mais doit au traitement des deee
permanent retour le long des auteurs
l'étude là autrement dit me permet avant
tout le monde aux terres le tutu une
chanson en français qui nous ramène aux
chemins de fer
vous savez que la toile est la retraite
a été a été modifié profondément dans le
chemin de fait parce qu'on avait les
tombeaux des régies bus des hommes
n'entrait plus dans les compartiments
des crinolines et les crinolines alors
il ya la cabine
il ya une chanson là dessus oui c'est
leur français crinoline 9 tab aux mines
le acheteurs exigent une bonne foi crise
on ne veut plus de toi le jour en
montant dans le train je suis coincé
dans la porte hier à saint luc le chef
de teint vienne m'a poussé par derrière
a ajouté l'édile
les pierres qui rare la chanson la plus
célèbre en photo à la meilleure c'est le
petit gars qui est un chef-d'oeuvre
carita voulait chanter d'or mêmes tics
un qu'un même type houchin maillot rouge
tonnes fera du chagrin
si on dort points jusqu alors c'est
l'histoire d'une pop dentellières qui
est vrai sur le grand filles mères on
parle pas de pelle qui gagne un franc
par jour les dentellières de lille
c'était vraiment les plus misérables
elles travaillaient dans des conditions
matérielles ce livre abominable et alors
elle cherche à endormir son enfant à
l'aide de pavot ou de je ne sais trop
quoi
houle en promettant la visite de saint
nicolas du père fouettard de ce qu'on
peut imaginer parce qu'elle a besoin de
travailler et alors ce qui est
absolument abominable dans une chanson
comme celle là c'est quand on s'aperçoit
qu'elle lui promet d'aller dégager au
mont-de-piété son beau sarraut son habit
du dimanche
s'il est sage bien mais qu'elle voulait
chanter cette chanson qu'on envoie là
quel est votre bateau à bout
moi je vis je vais pas chanter c'est
chez moi de bon lui semble sous la
saison des asperges et toutes les filles
de moules les souris car on prenait un
siège
jean fringant banal
c'était une émission tout à fait
étonnante parce qu'il y avait là seul
plateau un maire communiste professeur à
l'institut catholique vincenot ok t'es
que j'adorais vous saviez avec ses
moustaches et gilet de laine tricotés et
qui était un bourguignon un peu
réactionnaire et plus
pierre miquel qui est là qui est un
historien comment dirais-je haut-rhin
plus radicale voilà un peu comme ça donc
c'était quatre tempéraments différents
et vraiment c'est une union à la fin
dans les chansons du terroir c'était
quand même c'est assez formidable
quatrième bouquet de mots je me tourne
cette fois du côté d'académie concours
avec hervé bazin choisirait le mot vie
quand on est dans le dernier quart choi
veilleux ou veille veilleux veilleux
quand on est dans le dernier quart
chaque minute compte j'en souhaite 10
millions en tout les amis que j'ai ici
edmonde charles roux moi je crois que je
prendrai racines parce que tous les mots
ont des racines
françoise mallet joris j'aimerais bien
translucide à cause de l'étymologie de
la précision et de la musique
françois nourissier je prends le mot
visage parce qu'elle aille à la vision
et à la vie il ya l'âge il ya sage je
vous souhaite un mot superbe daniel
boulanger le mot francs je parle de la
monnaie est évidemment le franc francs
tran huy franc tout ouvrant tout grand
robert ce métier je prendrai le mot
cucurbitacées parce que j'aime les
légumes
michel tournier je choisirais laconique
parce que c'est un mot sonore coloré et
puis c'est une qualité qui je crois nous
réunit tout ce soir
alors il faut pas partie des camions
comme il vaut quand même répondre jean
françois revel et bien étonné
l'assistance et la circonstance je
choisirais le mot phrase jules roy
pour moi c'est de mon coeur que oui les
grandes passions viennent du coeur ces
vols militaires et je trouve qu'il n'ya
pas plus grand bonheur qu'entendre un
jour quelqu'un a plus dire mon cher
coeur jean lacouture adolescence
simplement parce que le mot est beau
sans référence biographique
autobiographique
merci alors les deux célèbres marguerite
avait séduit un très large de célèbres
marques de la littérature bien entendu
avait séduit un très large public quand
elle était passée à apostrophes écouter
les parler de l'écriture
marguerite duras d'abord et marguerite
yourcenar ensuite je reviens au style ce
qui est curieux c'est que vous faites
des répétitions volontaire vous placez
vous placer des mots d'une manière
bizarre qui doit effectivement heurté
des professeurs un peu plus résistant
c'est l'évidente bon et avec cette chose
cette chose
j'avais commencé avec hiroshima est très
correct c'est vrai il rêvait alors avec
ce style un peu bizarre un peu singulier
et c'est là le miracle c'est que vous
obtenez vous arrivez à dire les choses
d'une manière juste précise et rapide
c'est ça qui est étonnant mais ces gens
n'étaient pas sûrs avant pour lui les
ouvriers
je me disais on ne pourra pas tenir avec
ça à leur envier des phrases enfin dans
un déroulement plus classique de la
frappe
maintenant ça marche comme ça ça
fonctionne comme ça je disais que vous
savez que la ley lecture courante que je
cherchais depuis si longtemps vu la
teinte
maintenant j'en suis suivre et que
paraît que tu es au courant et je dirais
écriture presque 10
qui courent que plus près c'est
d'attraper des choses que de dire voyez
vous mais je parle de la crête des mots
c'est une écriture qui courait sur la
crête pour aller vite pour ne pas perdre
parce que quand on écrit c'est le drame
on oublie tout de suite et c'est affreux
quelquefois beady eye and andré à écrire
on croit que c'est facile c'est le
contraire vous le savez c'est l'enfer
les a gérées par n'en est pas là avant
c'était l'enfer
mais pas là je vous dirai ma colline jeu
sur le bonheur on peut aussi écrire sans
souffrir sans trop souffrir parce que
l'âge avancé dans l'inconnu je faisais
me suis dit fils je fais une chose
impossible
mais quand même c'était plus fort que
moi mais oui c'est très dur d'écrire ça
drôle de trip toutes les coutures
pourquoi on se double de sa ans se
double d'une heure d'une autre vision du
réel pourquoi tout le temps ce
cheminement de l'écrit à côté de la vie
est-ce que ça n'est pas
un grand d'altruisme pour vous qui créez
de passer des journées des mois et
probablement des années à traduire les
autres comment cette chose
bien sûr j'ai jamais fait de différence
entre vous et moi expliquez moi j'aime
bien il ya une vie est ce que très
souvent employée par les noms unum
sommes être multi mais je suis un mais
des multitudes sont en moi alors
vraiment que ce soit moi à qui et à quoi
il arrive quelque chose que ce soit
quelqu'un d'autre
j'avoue que je voudrais entendre que la
différence il avait traduit dès les
champs du negro spirituals avait les
trajets donc ce dépôt est assurée par la
protestation pour les minorités mais
finalement vous avez la tête plus
politique qu'on ne le croit
et alors quand aux poètes grecs enfin
que qu'un homme est écrit à deux très
beaux verres qui même sur la vie la mort
l'amour la politique ce soit moi qui les
écrit transports je ne vois pas la
différence
nous avons exprimé quelque chose qu'il
devait être exprimées et où si tu es
dans le vrai noir
cette devise alchimique aller vers
l'obscur et l'inconnu par ce qui est
plus obscur et inconnu encore est-ce que
ça n'est pas aussi le travail de
l'écrivain
absolument les mains se trouve et c'est
ce qui attend les crimes ainsi un temps
il se trouve dans cette matière informe
diverses compliquée qu'elle avait et il
est habile
la travail en le travaillant il va peu à
peu prendre un fort une se dit fière
ça donne certaines choses ça produit
certains effets et il nous permet aux
gens de faire ses expériences à travers
lui d'analyser leurs propres expériences
à travers les siennes
danièle sallenave danièle sallenave vous
aimez beaucoup marie tueur sonar alors
est ce que vous avez et émue l'a
retrouvé là de l'entendre et vous avez
bien faire parler des femmes écrivains
oui pour ça et j'admire beaucoup
marguerite yourcenar mais c'est pas
parce que c'est une femme jade jeu
l'avenir parce que c'est un très grand
écrivain aussi une petite poisse
non mais j'ai pensé pas non non je
l'admirais beaucoup parce que il ya une
singularité extrême dans son dans son
oeuvre et dans dans cette manière de se
dissimuler derrière son oeuvre en
prenant appui sur des hauts fonds sur
des territoires qui ne sont pas très
courant ni très commun elle s'est
absentée notre moment là vous essayez
lui faire dire qu'elle était un petit
peu engagés un peu plus mal a été elle a
été la langue et la partie cocoa des
combats écologie n'est pas dans son
oeuvre
temps fort est encore bon appui sur les
zones les plus lointaines elle prend
appui sur l'antiquité elle prend appui
sur le moyen âge ou la renaissance et je
dirais que dans la langue aussi son idée
de la langue française c'est pas une
idée que je partage dans le détail et on
n'est pas obligé de l'appliquer bien sûr
mais c'est que il faut s'appuyer sur ces
zones ancien latin le grec et finalement
c'est une grande classique des licences
qu'être à n'importe qui et mais aussi
george sand des peut totalement séduite
par le travail du genre est ce que vous
connaissiez je n'avais pas eu l'honneur
de rencontrer encore mathieu l'humain
mais j'avais été très ému au moment où
on avait parlé d' interrompre cette
publication faute de moyens laisse moi
un éditeur sera le mieux est un
mouvement vous regardiez
la maison dernier il n'y a pas résisté à
l'accord est dit non je ne suis pas
l'auteur de leur faillite ou deux mais
je connais heureusement que je vais m'en
voudrez mais je suis revenu je suis
passé ensuite j'ai dit sur delà des
presses de la cité et maintenant c'est
la maison bordas qui a repris mais
toujours sur l'étiquette garnier est ce
que vous lisez tout l'élève de georges
sand des paluds encore tout
oui mais je les lirais tout j'aime
beaucoup lire des correspondants sur les
correspondances les plus brillantes
c'était celle qu'elle avait éclos berre
mais je veux dire encore quand les
pontons du classique au fond dans
l'impression qu'on dit oui c'est quelque
chose d'un peu ennuyeux d'un peu de
rappel un peu solennel je crois que
c'est une femme qui n'est pas du tout de
rap et soul adele on en saura beaucoup
sur le sur les secrets de marguerite
yourcenar et sur ses passions avec la
biographie que nous prépare josyane
savigneau je crois font la rentrée
merci danièle sallenave la
correspondance de leurs jambes en
première il n'était pas non plus comme
je viens de gardanne et cela à quelqu'un
qui n'avait pas de modification en elle
cherche toujours à un retour aux
retrouver le monde autour d'elle elle
recréer une façon extraordinaire et et
sa correspondance a été réservé une
révélation pour beaucoup et beaucoup de
gens m'écrivent et me dise où me disent
qu'ils n'ont pas tellement aimer la
littérature de georges st mais qu'ils
aiment c'est quoi ce qu'ils aiment ça
corresponde question à quoi sert un
écrivain réponse de rené tremblay michel
tournier et milan kundera
je vais vous lire cette phrase qui était
le début d'un article vous consacré
récemment pierre assouline il disait
etiemble est un emmerdeur
mais il faut l'encourager à persévérer
alors d'abord est ce que ce mot moi j'ai
l'impression que vous l'aimez ce môme
herder part c'est un bon mot de la
langue française
mais est-ce qu'il vous va bien je n'ose
pas dire que je mérite car ce serait un
trop belles éloges
il me semble qu'il n'y a presque pas
l'emmerdeur dans la langue française
c'est à dire de gens qui disent toujours
ce qu'il pense de qui que ce soit et de
quelques idées que ce soit or il me
paraît aujourd'hui plus que jamais où le
rôle de l'écrivain doit lutter tant
qu'il peut
contre le rôle de ce qu'on appelle les
médias
il me paraît que l'écrivain doit être
par définition quel que soit son oeuvre
poétique littéraire critique dramatique
il doit être l'homme qui en mer pourquoi
parce qu'il dit sur tout le monde et sur
toute chose ce qu'il croit au prix de sa
vie être la vérité mais s'il n'y a pas
de moins en moins d'emmerdeur dans la
république des lettres j'en ai peur
parce que les lois du commerce sont ce
qu'elles sont il faut bien dire est qu
un emmerdeur ça ne se vend pas toujours
très bien la grande héroïne du compte
c'est sherazade l'histoire de shérazade
est typique
la voilà qui est mariée à un horrible
monsieur et à l'habitude de couper la
tête de la femme avec laquelle il vient
de passer la nuit
mais elle lui raconte des histoires et
quand le soleil se lève et s'arrête pile
il veut savoir la suite alors lui dit la
nuit prochaine et donc ils allaient
vivre et grâce donc à son art de
conteuse elle empêche cette horrible
tirant de commettre ses crimes
et je trouve que c'est fabuleux se
définit la vocation de la littérature
qui est de désarmer les tyrans pourquoi
y at il eu staline hitler et polpot et
quelques lots c'est de la faute de la
littérature c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas
eu les écrivains allemands pour hitler
ruche pour staline et ses terrains qui
ont été capables de les désarmer par
leur talent voilà à la question d'elle
de la larme quand on parle par exemple
de démocratie populaire de l'est ce sont
trois mensonges dans une seule phrase
par nation ni démocratie ni populaire ni
deux ni délai
mais ce n'est pas seulement une [ __ ]
intérim et ça ça change tout parce que
si vous dites ce sont les pays des rêves
alors tout est lourde
c'est tout à fait un autre si les pays
de l'est on en est c'est tout à fait un
autre si les pays de l'est appartient à
la grande empire d'alès mais ce ne sont
pas les pays de l'est alors vous voyez
avec un mauvais vocabulaire est seul à
penser très orwélienne espère avec le
mauvais vocabulaire on est pépin b hop
est une bonne pensée on est perdu et que
tout notre travail devrait être là la
vérification de chaque monstre en fin de
compte le des voix de l'écrivain dvs sur
la pureté de chaque mot le l'humilité le
appesanti 36,15 a fait une enquête sur
apostrophes et les unes des questions
qui étaient posées c'était quel est
votre meilleur souvenir d' apostrophes
et bien la réponse c'est marie tueur
sonar qui arrive très largement en tête
viennent ensuite
albert cohen georges dumézil claude
hagège qu'on verra tout à l'heure qu'on
entend notamment maurice genevoix henri
vincenot et puis après d'autres
évidemment duras dolto soljenitsyne et
c'est beaucoup d'autres alors à quoi
sert l'écrivain je vais demander c'est
au décès de questions jorge semprun
écrivain espagnol de langue française
et puis à tahar ben jelloun écrivains
marocains de langue française
d'abord jorge semprun l'écrivain ces
rappeurs ce qu'ont dit les écrivains
qu'on parlait là il sert à maintenir la
vérité des mots je ne suis pas sûr
qu'ils servent à abattre la dictature
rien que par leur talent parce qu'ils
avaient beaucoup d'écrivains allemand
que d'énormes talents
j'éprouvais benjamins à tata mais il
sert au moins à maintenir la vérité les
mots et le ce qu'on voit à l'est
aujourd'hui c'est justement ça les
écrivains sont les premiers rangs à la
première place parce qu'ils ont maintenu
pendant des années une vérité est qu'ils
ont maintenant le les porte parole de
cette vérité qui triomphe
mais quel est le rôle de l'écrivain
aujourd'hui dans une société comme la
nôtre que ce qu'elles soient espagnoles
ou française en 1936 quand on a fêté à
vienne le 50e anniversaire de r membres
à elias canetti a fait un discours il a
parlé des vertus de l'écrivain on va pas
tout les rappeler parce que ce serait
déjà trop l'eau mais il a dit une une
des vertus de l'écrivain il me parle de
broc il a dit c'est d'être toujours
contre le pouvoir
tahar benjelloun oui quand on vient d'un
pays du tiers-monde je pense que
un écrivain enfin d'écriture peut
paraître comme un luxe mais le silence
devient un crime à ce moment là parce
qu'il ya tellement de choses à dénoncer
tellement de choses à dire que le devoir
de l'écrivain c'est vraiment décrire les
dires même si son peuple ne n'est pas
capable de lire et c'est pour ça que
dans nos pays je dirais que les
écrivains sont des traducteurs du
silence d'immenses silence et des
traducteurs de clameur publique
extraordinaire et c'est eux qui sont à
l'écouté de ce peuple qui rapporte des
paroles qui doit absolument être
apportées il ne sert pas peut-être à
démolir les dictatures mais ils gênent
les dictatures
ils gênent les tyrans et je pense que
les écrivains sont plus en danger
dans les pays du tiers-monde content que
l'on ait pays
européens et occidentaux en général
merci alors là je me dirige vers la
cinquième salve de réponse cinquième
bouquet à la question quel est le mot de
la langue française que vous préférez à
tous quelles qu'en soient les raisons je
commence par alain minc
j'ai choisi par les temps qui courent un
mot immigré c'est à dire un mot
d'origine arabe et j'ai choisi zénith
madeleine chapsal moi j'ai choisi la
passion de la vérité parce que ce sont
deux mots que j'aime mais qui se pose et
qui a pas moyen de réconcilier jean
ferniot bernard pivot m'excuseras il y
en a deux allez-y le premier c'est
tendresse et le second cet enthousiasme
geneviève normal pour moi c'est le mot
partir que je trouve le plus beau de la
langue française
et comme disait paul moreau c'est le
rêve de tout bon projectiles
philippe labro nostalgie parce que c'est
un mot qui sonne bien il à la musique et
il évoque les émotions l'enfance et
l'adolescence qui sont à des thèmes sur
lequel je sais tu travailles et frédéric
dard et écouter à cause de sa
connotation érotique et seulement qu'aux
cela scelle mode à bernard clavel
insoumis que j'illustre par cette phrase
de gide le monde ne sera sauvé s'il peut
l'être que par des insoumis gilles
perrault oui ce pourrait être le mot
forfaiture parce qu'une cour d'appel
d'aix-en-provence il est vrai viens me
condamner à verser 18 millions de
centimes à des policiers marseillais
pour avoir 1 s'est qualifié leur
conduite
alors j'ai le droit de dire que le mot
forfaiture et pour moi le mot le plus
cher de la langue française et je
continue de chéri
j'ai masseube acheter un dictionnaire
des synonymes
françois de closets rampant sens qui
s'est dit tout à l'heure à propos de la
chine et de l'union soviétique
je pense que c'est le mot vérité me
rappelant de ce que disait rémy de
gourmont ce qui est terrible avec la
vérité c'est que quand on la cherche
on la trouve merci j'ai intitulé les
deux extraits d'émissions que vous allez
voir qu'ils ne sont pas tristes les
jouissances extravagantes savait qu'on
appelle la masturbation en créole dieu
seul me voit ça s'appelle dieu seul me
voit ça comme ça donc il y a oui mais là
vous mélangez beaucoup la religion et
l'érotisme à la maman vous dites oh
emilie brawn qui a les fesses en
alléluia vous savez n'a encore alléluia
peau pourquoi j'appuie alléluia bon ça
te cris d'allégresse moi je pense que
l'amour tout un mot qui se respecte doit
finir un échange simultané mahal et
allègre joyeux mais j'ai appris depuis
parce que je découvre des choses après
savourer et molly vous n'est ce pas que
il ya beaucoup de femmes qui au moment
et des hommes aussi d'ailleurs
au moment d'aller dire bonjour aux
enjeux simultanément
we cry alléluia j'avais une amie
un soir et tout à coup il fait la
coquette autour d'un grand échalas la
propulsion retrait je la rencontre peu
de temps après et je lui dis alors dit
oui c'est fini
j'ai commencé je reviens pas c'est ici
c'était tout passé mais j'ai fini je
peux pas rester avec un type qui au
moment le plus vif me dit ma substance
ma substance pas une raison c'était une
offrande du dit non elle m'a fait
j'avais l'impression d'une m'offre rien
mais que je le volet alors c'est un peu
fait des quantités de l'histoire comme
ça mais qui ne peuvent pas faire ça peut
faire eu une courte histoire mais pas
une nouvelle
c'était daniel boulanger et frédéric
dard oui alors s'il ya quelqu'un qui a
une sexualité extravagantes ardent
débridé c'est bien évidemment votre
personnage bérurier est ce que vous
pourriez nous définir la sexuelle la
sexualité de bérurier en quelques mots
là vous me posez une colle sorte au
milieu d'une assemblée pareil autres
illustres je crois que pour berrier de
la sexualité peut se résumer en ces
termes
ça tient chaud ça tient compagnie ça
coûte pas cher et ça peut rapporter gros
j'ai remarqué en face hier c'est pas ils
sont soumis tous neufs académicien
français ce qu'il y en a partout on sait
pas où mettre les pieds
ben oui est ce que ça vous fait pas
envie quand même d'aller les rejoindre
d'ailleurs je vous ai mis de leur côté
ça vous fait pas envie quand même
d'ailleurs les rejoindre il ya votre
amie part au delpech du tour vous aimez
bien ils sont tous prêts à voter pour
ceux que j'aime bien sûr tous prêts à
voter pour vous les copains quand on est
à table et ça va pas plus loin
non mais non franchement y est nommé
vraiment et vous ne pouvez pas aller
chez eux
écoutez d'abord il faudrait qu'ils ont
déjà demandé ils se disent on fait des
pétitions pour que vous alliez recruter
demandé à monsieur peyrefitte qui
s'emporte me regardé d'un drôle d'oeil
encore que ça soit le rêve de sa vie de
me voir be corner à son côté assez
dommage qu'on n'ait pas un micro il a
pas mis qu'on peut pas donner un mini
quoi monsieur perfide s'il vous plaît
soyez gentils d'ollé nicolle vraiment
monsieur peyrefitte vous feriez pas pour
san antonio frédéric dard et monsieur
perfide sais même pas qui je suis en
très beau mais je n'ai pas pétitionner
pour lui non d'ailleurs je pétitionnent
jamais mais vous pourriez voter pour lui
pourquoi pas oui c'est bon qu'est-ce qui
peut voter pour lui là aussi à mes côtés
raymond devos
vous n'êtes pas il fait partie la cad
images il a pris la place de nadau coke
était pas il devait partir il a eu
l'honneur d'une inauguration et il a
pris sa chaise pas son fauteuil depuis
un quart de oui oui j'en ai joué occuper
un siège c est ce qu on est bien du côté
des ministres et de l'académie à on dit
rires oui c'est on est très à l'aise
voyez très à l'aise on se sent bien et
en confiance bien
alors maintenant il y a eu on va parler
des rencontres insolites fait qu'ils
aient eu beaucoup de rencontres
insolites apostrophe citerai pour
mémoire michel jobert et guy bedos il ya
eu pierre bourdieu et pierre perret nous
avons choisi deux c'est la rencontre de
georges brassens et du général bigeard
est celle de claude hagège et de raymond
devos
vous avez porté l'uniforme non premier
forme j'étais trop jeune au moment de la
guerre et devant le drapeau ça faisait
mais un drapeau non absolument pas non
moi j'aime je n'aime pas ma patrie moi
j'aime la france
aucun rapport et la marseillaise non la
musique n'est pas mal les paroles je
prédis souhaitable
bigeard est un de vos admirateurs c'est
vrai a beaucoup ses chansons ben oui
mais oui alors c'est le seul qui fasse
l'unanimité ces brassages on est tous
d'accord que nous aimons tous bons et
quel courage
toute sa vie des jeunes et chanter ça
c'est autre chose c'est un gendarme
j'oublie quand même vous savez je suis
en face des militaires suis anti
militariste et que je les approuve
totalement qu'on le soit m'enfin chaque
centime et c'est pas les gens de droite
mais sous le militaire non mais si cet
homme comme ce flic là m'a rendu service
à un moment de ma vie
j'oublie j'oublie que nous ne sommes pas
d'accord des militants du service n'ont
cessé les premiers maintenant est ce
qu'on peut bien parler
excusez moi est ce qu'on peut bien
parler une langue sens quand on ne
l'écrit pas combien de temps ça je crois
pas bien entendu si peu bien là parler
bien entendu quand on n'a pas vu les
mots écrits et quelles raisons
contraires au contraire l'écriture peut
être un obstacle puisque l'écriture
souvent envoyé trois françaises que les
enfants autant de mal à apprendre
s'éloigne de la prononciation d'un
obstacle et vous qui connaissez
tellement de langues
c'est très bien quand on commence à
prendre l'eau il faut apprendre le verbe
si on n'a pas des points de repère très
vite la langue il faut avoir vu quand
même il faut l'avoir vu écrit sans ça
what do you want what do you do you -
écoutez monsieur devos à un de vos
sketches à montparnasse gascon bâti en
septembre 82 vous avez imiter le
japonais vous souvenez vous cependant
votre imitation était remarquable
c'était une voyait japonais ce qui
existe et c'est ça ça a existé
oui vous n'avez pas dû écrire et
pourtant vous limitiez vous êtes un
grand admirateur de 2
je suis un spectateur admiratif oui
j'aime cette façon de se prendre la
langue dans des toiles d'araignée des
mots j'aime qu'il soit ce qu'il est
c'était un prince un prince de l'absurde
mais un prince en vitre pour écouter
vraiment pas
[Applaudissements]
claude hagège et raymond devos voile et
voilà comme il était dans cette émission
vous ne retirez évidemment aucun des
compliments que vous avez fait à raymond
devos le contraire même genre doublerait
et dresser contre il ce jour-là par deux
paraissiez contrit contrit oui parce que
j'étais un public réduit à une personne
oui oui oui bah oui avait peu de
personnes mais raymond devos aviez fait
cette déclaration au cours de cette
émission n'était pas dans l'extrême vous
aviez dit que l'homme de parole c'était
le type de grippe de claude hagège
c'était votre livre de chevet oui c'est
vrai alors il faut quand même savoir
c'est un livre qui ne peut être lus que
par quelques centaines de personnes tout
au plus
il ya d'ailleurs eu un malentendu
extraordinaire de ce livre c'est que moi
j'aime manger dit vous avez le livre de
codage est un livre très difficile à
lire mais personnellement entendu on a
entendu que vous qui disiez et quelques
est linguiste extraordinaire et vous
savez que ce livre a été vendu à
plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'exemplaires alors qu'ils n'étaient
destinés qu'à quelques centaines d rudy
n'est ce pas vrai monsieur je pense que
c'est faux comment sa peau ce livre est
destiné à faire connaître un minimum de
linguistique à un large public et il a
réussi
hélas modérément
non c'est très bien quand même c'était
moi je me rappelle j'ai souffert sang et
eau pour lire votre livre vii était
rigolote attention bernard pivot
ah non non non car en fait certes il a
bénéficié d'une promotion qui est celle
du moyen du média
oui votre lettre débonnaire mais il
était destiné j'ai écrit des livres bien
plus technique est bien plus difficile à
lire oui d'accord mais qui sont vendus à
quelques centaines d'exemplaires était
destiné à la victoire confidentiel
tandis que là il s'est vendu à combien
de dizaines de milliers d'exemplaires
selon l'éditeur le sait voyons enfin il
a dû facebook 40 ou 50 me mais tout ça
c'est quand même bien de devos qui a dit
non mais vous avez quand même raconté
une blague ce soit l'accepter de votre
livre de chevet c'est pas vrai de vaud
mais j'ai des insomnies
il n'y a qu'une chose que même dont vous
n'avez pas parlé
c'est de la langue de bois à la langue
de bois j'ai parlé ce que vous avez
parlé de toutes les langues sauf de
l'année j'en ai parlé longuement oui
mais vous n'avez pas défini mais il y en
a pas alors oui alors précisément j'ai
demandé à raymond devos de nous parler
de la langue de bois oui parce que vous
savez les gens ne savent pas trop ce que
c'est que la langue de bois c'est vrai
on entend souvent parler de la langue de
bois que les politiciens
il ya des gens qui savent pas ce que
c'est quand ils entendent langue de bois
savent quoi et moi j'ai un fils qui ne
savait pas ce que c'était j'ai un fils
depuis quelques temps il m'inquiétait
il mangeait plus il refusait toute
nourriture révolue mettre n'importe quoi
dans son assiette il y touchez pas
j'étais obligé de donner aux chats et
aux chiens alors un sens je lui dis mais
qu'est ce que tu veux il dit je veux de
la langue de bois
évidemment j'ai tout de suite compris
qu'il prenait la langue de bois pour une
d'oreilles comestibles alors que comme
chacun sait la langue de bois c'est la
langue dont se servent les politiciens
quand il parle pour ne rien dire
c'est une langue tout juste bonne pour
alimenter la conversation sujet moi
alors je dis à mon fils c'est aimer la
langue de bois c'est un vent ça n'est
pas fou j'en mangerais g l filmant je
l'apprends de la langue de boeuf j'aime
pas le bol de la langue de bouton j'aime
ne vous faites pas de vaud enfin leveaux
jeunes que le bois le petit est mort le
rhône est mort alors que le bois lui et
les vivants j'ai dit il faisant allusion
aux peut-être bel et filandreux mail
montcharmont gens ne voudraient pas
vivre à bout de la langue de moi dit il
en appelle à nous le salon il en
demandait pas si tu vas le bras talent
doit alors j'ai pris mon fils à
provisions ces schémas dit donnez moi
une langue de bois s'il vous plaît bien
tendres et son noeud si c'est possible
pas pour moi c'est pour mon fils dit oui
monsieur dans quel bois tu comment quel
bois bruit ou dit dubois de boeuf du
bois de mouton ou du bois de vaux mais
je dis monsieur mon fils ne mange pas de
ce mois là et alors du bois dont on fait
les chevaux c'est qu'elle soit voulue
des chevaux de bois
si oui donnez moi les mille ans avant me
suis dit comprendre le cheval entier
celle comprise
je ne fais pas de carte c'est monsieur
donnez-moi le cheval entier d'accord
déjouant valse des noms mais directement
dans mon fils à provisions dit voilà
enveloppé ces polémiques
je vous mets quelques copeaux le chien
j'ai un chat hausse
alors un peu de sueur pour le chat la
cyber sinkou combien je vous dois je
prie je ramène le chat la maison quand
mon fils l'a découvert le cheval dans
son assiette et à bien manger la langue
mais à la réception
alors là j'comprends pas là se comprend
plus parce que mon fils qui lisez
toujours le bois si vivement le bois
c'est vivant les restes du cheval savez
vous ce qui rend la fête du bois mort et
où l'histoire se complique c'est que ce
matin je reçois un coup de fil du match
en bois qui dit qui me dit monsieur le
chèque en bois
[Rires]
vous êtes un admirateur de vodka
remparts et sans condition qu'ils ne
seraient admirateur de gros cet instinct
longueur cette magicienne la langue est
alors lui il peut postuler je crois à
l'académie à baham ont donc vous est-ce
que vous souhaitez vous prédire d'entrée
d'académie c'est très joli mais je n'en
ai pas les mérites pour le dictionnaire
bien la viande les mots pourquoi pas de
la viande de veau la viande de veau
devons choisir le renard en plus la
viande en place et quand tu vois deux vo
ça veut dire le renard en flamand oui je
suis un de vos viandes grenat ce sont
[Rires]
des sketches qui s'échangent d'écrire un
livre sur la langue française merci à
tous à tous les tours à tous les quatre
maintenant loges et illustrations par
les maux par les mots toujours de la
francophonie américaine vous dit pas je
piquais tout de la race des traces ou
bouba sare gaillou et dévergondée que
c'est que ça rejaillit salgai où il ya
le mot qui maintenant commence à être
connue ce qui s'appelle sa guise et
salgai ou pourraient avoir les mêmes
racines de sa green qui a aussi sa
gouaille bien entendu mais en acadie on
dit sagouine cygwin salgai où tout ça a
d'abord dans l'oreille on le sent si je
dis carassou c'est pas mal déjà mais
quand c'est ça un voyou setrag sous le
nom le dit
c'est dans la bouche coinçant sauf que
quand la sagouine à jouer en province
je crois que c'est en vendée toute la
salle a sauté on s'est souvenu de ce
moulin alors vous voudront donc
volontiers un autre mot les soeurs en
restèrent kalou et tente alors nous
injecte alouettes je fais ça je bic
mais là encore si vous bi clé en
akkadien vous pouvez vite et vous
connaissez
bigler une chute simplement non pas
j'habite lancement le battement de
paupière c'est tout oui vous voilà un
savant qui est obligé de dire battement
des paupières alors que nous disons mais
kalou était il s'est dit je voudrais que
vous avez l'habitude de lire en public
vous alors moi j'aimerais qu'ils lisent
y est par exemple ce poème s'intitule
non vous pouvez me bâillonner m'enfermer
avec votre argent en chine fusil avec
vos pas lisez vos lois je vous réponds
non je vous réponds je recommence je
vous garoche mes volets de copeaux dane
de deezer homicide
je vous magan je vous use je vous rends
fou je vous fais honte vous ne m'aurez
pas vous devrez m'abattre avec ma tête
de tucson deneux de bois de souche ma
tête de semailles nouvelle j'ai
endurance g/kwh un dépôt de babiche
montgrand s'exclame je me désinvesti de
vous je vous ai chaque des sommeils
bouge la poitrine résonne j'ai retrouvé
l'avenir
super là vous voyez j'ai beau ça oui oui
c'est parce que j'ai voulu cette langue
qui était humiliée dévalorisé et cetera
au moment où j'ai commencé d'écrire en
1950 quand nous étions dans un que de
déculturation sans nom sans nom et où je
parle d'aliénation d'où je parle de
libération en contrepartie
eh bien j'ai voulu faire de cette langue
de se parler et de cette écriture
humilié j'ai voulu en faire une langue
littéraire sont les palmes académiques
vous avez sur votre vie je trouve
vraiment c'est quelqu'un les mérites
c'est bien beau mais je trouve que s'il
ya je ne sais pas un ministre qui est
devant son petit poste ou à plus forte
raison le premier ministre présent la
pluie je trouve qu on voudrait vous
donner la légion d'honneur si quelqu'un
mérite la légion d'honneur
et bien c'est vous et j'espère qu'on ne
va le faire très rapidement parce que
tout ce que vous avez fait pour le
français langue française en louisiane
c'est vraiment extraordinaire et je
demande chose rare ici nos émissions
qu'on applaudit ton applaudissements jon
cassar votre âge et votre éditeur m'a
dit que juste avant de venir ici vous
buviez chanter une chanson une petite
chanson bannière dans votre livre il ya
des deux chansons la p'tite chanson que
j'ai chanté saison en créole c'est à
dire etc on se moque maintenant des
quelques fois des noirs qui essayait
passé pour blanc c'est lé noir même qui
se moquaient d'eux alors c'est une
petite chanson comme ça ça va
khademi l'atla au monsieur bonjour
comment lien solent d'admis l'atla au
monsieur bonjour comment lien sol en
chapeau côté homsy bonjour badine à la
même si bonjour juillet fait coin coin
oh mais c'est bonjour idar à la bouche
même si ben laden il est là on est sur
un jour libre à lille
m
[Musique]
voilà donc trois représentants éminents
de la langue française savoureux aussi
surtout la langue française au nord des
états unis
yves berger et philippe labro vous êtes
tous les deux
les spécialistes des états unis
connaissait très bien la langue anglaise
alors qu'elle est je vous pose la
question tous les deux qu'ils aient la
chance de la langue française dans ces
trois pays d'auge nom de palais alors je
réponds en louisiane se terminer c'est
mort c'est terminé pour la simple raison
que en louisiane les petits enfants qui
naissent les bébés naissent plus en
français et le français n'est obligé de
la prendre à l'école en plus de ça il y
à un louisiane une minorité noire
extrêmement important qui considère que
le combat pour la défense la promotion
l'avenir du français n'est pas le sien
donc c'est terminé et en acadie c'est à
dire le pays d'où vient antonine maillet
le nouveau-brunswick et
l'île-du-prince-édouard
seule la langue française est en danger
il n'est que qui n'est qu'au québec où
la langue française les fortes et a les
meilleures chances de durer
surtout si comme j'en fais très
profondément le veut et ce ton combat
comme ça que je mène depuis 25 ans le
québec acquiert son indépendance
on peut considérer on peut considérer
qu'à ce moment là cette province du
canada
devenue une nation se donnera les moyens
se donnera les lois qui permettront à la
langue française à la langue française
qui est parlée la bac qui n'est pas tout
à fait la note de s'accomplir comme elle
doit le faire et cette dignité dont
parlait gaston miron et bien
s'accomplira parfaitement philippe labro
il a d'autant plus raison ivko aux états
unis la langue française a rarement eu
de chance il faut bien voir que quand
vous receviez des écrivains américains
vont trier vos livres
livres que vous recevez c'est-à-dire de
traduit de l'américain il y en à quoi
une douzaine par semaine du traduits du
français à new york à washington wire
rien par an la littérature française n'a
aucune chance parce qu'il existe comme
dans le cinéma un véritable
protectionnisme américain et
deuxièmement et c'est un phénomène très
intéressant et qui concerne évidemment
d'abord les états unis les états unis 6
paniz qui se francise évidemment pas
mais on considère d'ores et déjà que
dans une cinquantaine d'années
l'amérique ne sera plus blanche sera
métissée à cause de l'arrivée massive de
l'immigration latine qui vient
d'amérique latine et par conséquent
alors française n'a aucune chance
sauf certains îlots isolés dans
certaines universités où il ya encore
l'adulent québec quelques bugs abello
québec wymeersch la raison dieu merci
elle québec
enfin le québec c'était un mouchoir de
poche sur cet immense continent
merci à tous les deux joué tout de même
justement un mouvement est même des
professeurs nombreux l'université qui
connaissent le français qui traduisent
des romans de genre sont entre autres
attendus et qui font des îlots l'école
lesquels les îles en lutte parce que
justement ils luttent contre les
espagnols avec quelques remarquables
universitaires américains dans une
petite bande mince sur la côte est qui
aime qui connaissent parfaitement bien
la langue française est d'ailleurs les
grands biographe américain s'attaque
très régulièrement au grand écrivain
français est sévèremment rarissime
merci merci ils étaient ils étaient
russes de naissance il écrivait en
anglais ils habitaient les états unis à
la fin de sa vie il habitait la suisse
il parlait le français avec érudition et
une formidable gourmandise il a donné
naissance à lolita
il s'appelle vladimir nabokov bon
nabokov
c'est lolita c'est l'équation qu'on
entend toujours nabokov cellulite à
lorsqu'elle vous n'êtes pas un peu agacé
à la fin par le succès de l'habitat qui
a été si considérables qu'on risque de
penser que vous êtes le père d'une seule
petite fille un peu pervers
et bien lolita n'est pas une jeune fille
perverse
c'est une pauvre enfant une pauvre que
l'on débouche donc l'essence ne savez
jamais sous les caresses de de l'immonde
monsieur en berbère à qu'elle demande
une fois est-ce qu'on va toujours vivre
comme ça en faisant toutes sortes de
choses dégoûtantes dans des lits
d'aubert mais pour répondre à votre
question non
son succès ne m'agace pas je ne suis pas
conan doyle qui passe ne biz ou simple
bêtise préféré est reconnu comme
l'auteur d'une histoire d'afrique qu'il
croyait bien supérieure à son charles
cros
non seulement la perversité de cette
pauvre enfant a été grotesquement
exagéré mais son aspect physique son âge
tout at a été modifié par des
illustrations dans les publications
étrange des filles de 20 ans ou
davantage de grandin des déchets 082 les
trottoirs des modèles bon marché que ses
joues des simples criminels aux longues
jambes sont baptisés n'est fait
ou lolita dans des reportages de
magazine italien français allemand etc
lolita la nymphette n'existe qu'à
travers la hantise qui détruit imbert et
voici un aspect essentiel d'un livre
singulier qui a été faussée savoir une
popularité factice 6e
il pouvait applaudir nabokov oui parce
qu'il est un génie
[Applaudissements]
6e bouquet de mots préférés
jean-marie voir mon mot préféré c'est le
mot adolescence parce que l'adolescent
veut vivre ses rêves et qu'il est ainsi
le frère de l'écrivain bernard henri
lévy moi j'ai choisi un mot que je
trouve très beau etc et surtout le
dernier mot d'un très beau roman les
liaisons dangereuses c'est le mot de
consolation
yves berger pour moi c'est le mot rare
le mot acte h à rta cause de cette
phrase extraordinaire dans le voyage à
l'amérique de châteaubriant il me sert
avec des actes par des chemins de
loutres je vois il faudrait peut-être
répéter leur acte h à rt hrt qui est la
corde du pendu
nicolas brill alors ce soir simplement
pour le jeu et pour les sonorités ça
sera la pila julie c'est très beau l'api
lazuli annie ernaux moi c'est le mot
histoire parce que ça désigne à la fois
la vider tous les hommes à travers le
temps et aussi les choses qu'on se
raconte qu'on raconte aux autres et
qu'on se raconte à soi même qu'on écrit
cavanna patron je peux pas choisir
ac je viens à toi mais bon je vais
changer d'une poignée libellules à cebu
innocence bol ignominieusement encore
libellules et ignominieusement un
millecamps kadri merioua plaisir c'est
un mot qui est très français
cette règne sur le s vient à mourir sur
hyères et je trouve c'est un mot qui est
plus beau en français dans notre langue
olivier todd sérénité parce que c'est le
contraire de l'anc c'était de l'
angoisse c'est difficile d je trouve que
c'est plus beau que sont synonymes le
bonheur merci c'était des philosophes et
ils sont venus par quelques-uns même
souvent apostrophe vous allez je pense
retrouver avec plaisir dans l'ordre non
vrai d'abord retrouver roland barthes
raymond aron mais d'abord maurice clavel
face à des curés marxiste oui ce livre a
fait les conversions j'en conviens ce
sont celles étudiants le jeune
professeur c'est l'instituteur c'est
l'infirmière ccc pressé de presque des
des ouvriers des ouvriers que qui
viennent pas à ça des centaines et des
milliers qui m'écrivent mathieu pour
m'avait fait réaliser que j'avais la foi
je l'avais et je n'osais pas croire que
je croyais parce que je pensais que du
temps de mark ii faut qu on ne pouvait
plus croire je le livre congrès cela
c'était moins dur et par milliers je le
livre très humblement à votre attention
autrement dit padre moi je crois que
l'efficacité de ce livre n'a pas été le
témoignage brûlant etc
ça a été une rupture de front
idéologique et culturelle j'ai envoyé
pardonnez-moi contre le boulaq
culturelle de ce temps est d'abord
marsistes une sorte de commandos-suicide
il s'est trouvé sur une percée
victorieuse sans doute parce que le
goulag culturel marxiste en face était
très fatigué et épuisé
et voilà pourquoi vendre et je ne vous
parlerai pas avec animosité pourtant
mais je vous parlerai peut-être
messieurs extraire avec une certaine
douleur une certaine déploration en dix
ans 1
pardonnez moi c'est bien le moment de
découvrir le marxisme à l'heure où
personne n'en veut plus à leur opéra la
leur ou les marxistes en doute alors que
alors ou alors on paru pardonnez-moi de
l'île bon disons le mien d'abord qui
montre que marx et le goulag une autre
liste très important celui de glucksmann
la cuisinière le mangeur d'hommes qui
parti c'est le processus inverse qui
montre que le goulag ses marques alors
je vous demande et que faites-vous du
goulag êtes vous prêt à sacrifier vos
prévost vos frères martyrs et de là bas
pour un sourire carnassier de georges
marchais
roland barre ce livre est né dites-vous
delà de cette constatation c'est que
l'extraordinaire solitude du discours
amoureux exposants déballent c'est que
dans l'époque actuelle
disons cette espèce d'amour passion
d'amour romantique il faut bien le dire
disons en gros il n'est plus à la mode
il a probablement une grande audience
populaire mais il n'est plus à la mode
c'est à dire qu'il n'est pas prise en
charge par les grands langage théorique
ou réflexif ou idéologique que la
modernité a produit ce qui fait que si
on a à faire un sujet amoureux qui a une
certaine teinture de culture
intellectuelle
et bien ce sujet là s'il met advient de
tomber amoureux va se trouver
extrêmement solitaire il essaiera main
comme il souffre il essaiera de
s'appuyer sur un langage théorie qui qui
qui l'aident qui le prennent en charge
et dans l'époque actuelle il ne trouvera
rien comment expliquez-vous que sartre
qui quand on sait qui s'est souvent
trompé dans son jugement sur l'histoire
et plus d'influencé sur la genèse de la
jeunesse que vous qui contraire avait
souvent vu juste quand on écrit ce que
j'ai écrit sans avoir derrière soi ce
que sartre avait c'est à dire ses pièces
de théâtre c'est ces grands livres
littéraires être simplement disons un
écrivain politique qui souvent disait
une vérité
désagréable c'était normal que je ne
fusent pas toujours suivies par les
jeunes gens aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y
en a un certain nombre qui ne serait pas
indigner d'être dans mon camp c'est déjà
quelque chose s'ils notent ils n'avaient
pas été préparées gars forts et puis
vous intitulé votre livre avoir toujours
avoir toujours raison est un grand
heures non pourquoi
parce que je n'ai pas toujours eu raison
est que je déteste cette formule dans
toute la mesure du possible dans mes
mémoires
je n'ai pas pris le ton triomphaliste
jeu les beats gelé bien dit non je ne
l'ait pas fait et chaque fois que je
donne un exemple où j'ai eu raison j'y
ajoute immédiatement une autre occasion
où je me suis trompé
voilà et maintenant on va parler
d'émergence et lévis vous savez qu'il
n'a jamais pardonné à l'allemagne
jankélévitch nazis sa barbarie de
génocide
au point de refuser de s'intéresser à
tous ceux qui étaient en provenance de
l'allemagne y compris y compris la
musique y compris la philosophie
voici la dîmière jankélévitch imaginons
un philosophe allemand né en 46 et
maintenant il a donc plus de 30 ans il a
écrit vous la verriez pas responsable si
on ne liriez pas non parce que non pas
parce que je le poursuis de ma haine et
puisqu'il est par en effet il n'est pas
responsable mais j'ai quelque chose et
passionnante à faire à lire j'ai pas le
temps et par conséquent je veux bord de
chose incontestable
par exemple mon intérêt pour la pièce de
visite à vienne pour la purifier
espagnol que mon père mais guy gras de
sang latin dans les veines
elle met beaucoup c'est lui qui m'a
appris à référé la philosophie
l'italienne lapize espagnol de la mode
gracianne par exemple mon beau frère
également et donc tout cela j'ai trouvé
des compensations au delà de mon
espérance et que je me demandais
pourquoi les français sont tellement
hypnotisé obsédé
fasciné par le monstre allemand il ya un
côté de fascination maladive la grande
admiration de l'allemagne
l'humiliation devant l'allemagne la
l'autoflagellation devant le monstre
allemand et de dédale absolument pas
justifiée pour ce les nations apparenté
à la nation française et qui ont une
philosophie et combien original la
philosophie espagnol n'était plus
original jamais autant regretté que
depuis la prière de ne pas savoir
l'espagnol mais je comprends mais il y
en vous un être de chair et de sang qui
refusent une sorte de réconciliation
avec l'allemagne que pourrait lui
proposer le philosophe et penseur en
cela je suis pas très raisonnable je le
reconnais ma foi je me console moi même
en me disant que j'ai bien d'autres
choses la vertu est beaucoup plus
intéressante et qu'il ya un
rétrécissement de la pensée française
depuis longtemps parce qu'un et
hypnotisé par ce monstre et que en somme
elle a créé sa propre défaite
voici la 7e et avant dernière salve de
mots je vais commencer par max gallo oui
hérésie parce que je crois c'est un mot
qui me plaît et je crois qu'il ya
toujours trop de bien pensants france
huser source parce que c'est un mot qui
se prononce avec tout le corps on le dit
pas du bout des lèvres il n'est au fond
de la gorge puis il montre le sens très
fort
et puis se termine sur un centre est
doux comme si le mot s'enfuyait comme si
c'était un poisson qui filait dans les
mains lors on a envie de le poursuivre
emmanuel le roy ladurie baroque à la
fois protestants et catholiques ou henri
iv cyrano hélène carrère d'encausse
passe muraille parce que je voudrais
rendre hommage à marcel aymé que j'aime
énormément parce qu'aussi passé les
murailles avec son corps ou avec son
esprit c'est le meilleur moyen
d'acquérir les libertés et enfin parce
que c'est un mot avec un trait d'union
c'est extrêmement jolie jacques attali
tendres parce que le verbe veut dire
vouloir l'adjectif veut dire douceur et
j'aime bien l'idée que le bonheur ce
soit de mettre la volonté au service de
la douceur danièle sallenave
moi j'ai choisi un mot qui m'aide à
comprendre le rapport des mots et des
choses
certains mots qui contient tout c'est le
mot monde vous ne pouvez pas imaginer
quoi que ce soit aucun mot aucune chose
qu'ils ne fassent pas partie du monde
pierre nora oh moi j'ai beaucoup hésité
c'est très beau mot que son esprit
commentaires l'infini je me suis rabattu
sur un très pauvres le débat jean tulard
ranchon pourquoi parce que ronchonner
typiquement français regardez le
cardinal de richelieu pas par philippe
de champaigne il a une allure rang shon
et regarder napoléon il met sa main dans
son gilet pourquoi pour ne pas
l'attendre à son vis-à-vis
c'est ça les arrange on christine de
rivoyre choisi le mot honneur au
singulier toujours au singulier pas au
pluriel parce que c'est moins sûr lucien
bodard abaissement plus près apaisement
parce que j'ai consacré ma mère m'avait
la violence je suis né au milieu de la
violence des seigneurs de la guerre en
chine plus tard je me suis trouvée sur
la frontière des ardennes au moment où
les allemands attaquent et j'ai besoin
en fuite j'ai vécu les événements
tragiques cacao d'événements et ensuite
cette violence je l'aimais
professionnellement j'ai été à témoins
j'ai été un beau tour il s'est précipité
sur tous les charniers tous les cas
d'art et maintenant j'en ai assez et je
cherche avant tout la tranquillité la
paix le bonheur merci
irène frain
j'ai pris le mot secret mais je ne vous
dirai pas pourquoi parce que sinon je ne
serais pas du tout fidèle à mon choix
jacques lanzmann j'ai choisi le mot
hasard parce que le hasard est souvent
très hasardeuse et j'aime quand il tombe
sur la tête et qui vient me chahuté le
coeur régine deforges j'ai choisi le
veau plaisir au pluriel parce que la vie
nous en donne plusieurs merci voici
maintenant la séquence certainement la
plus émouvante de cette soirée
il nous parle de la mort ils nous
parlent de dieu vous avez entendre
successivement françoise dolto albert
cohen georges dumézil et marcel
jouhandeau à dolto vous êtes une
chrétienne convaincu oui depuis après ma
psychanalyse
avant d'ajouter chrétienne parce que
tout leur est chrétien mais après j'ai
compris que c'était une relation
extraordinaire quand elles n'étaient pas
vécu de façon des roses et qu'il y avait
dans l'évangile tout ce que la
psychanalyse découvre c'est à dire que
la dynamique est plus que la morale que
c'est ça surtout est d'ailleurs le
christ tout le temps les enfants
si nous nous ressemblons pas des enfants
nous n'entrons pas dans le royaume de
dieu qu'est le royaume de la dynamique
et puis toute façon inconsciente la
vierge saint joseph
et puis jésus c'est que nous c'est
encore une famille et qui alors qu'il
familles avec un enfant quand même qui
sort de l'ordinaire
justement c'est une famille symbolique
extraordinaire cet enfant qui est qui
est le père de sa mère
d'où les deux livres vous avez trois
livres la fois aux risques des
psychanalyses l'évangile au risque d'un
psy canalise oui c est ce qu on peut
dire que par exemple
bon alors jésus jésus pour vous un dd
des hommes de votre vie ah oui
absolument pour moi c'est le maître du
désir m inégal et dont tous les autres
qui sont aussi des maîtres du désir dans
les cultures diverses sont comme des
approches que le christ a lui même
incarné en même temps que il était homme
en même temps pas une fois on ne peut
prendre en défaut que c'est dès que ces
paroles sont en rapport avec ses actes
et ses actes sont des paroles acté c'est
fantastique
alors que je toujours les humains ont à
dire quelque chose enfin des humains les
plus les plus
les plus spirituelles il désavoue la
chair le christ n'a absolument pas
désavouer la chair ce qui est
extraordinaire
alors dieu j'ai vous allez ne pas me
croire je respect je vénère dieu notre
dur mais en quoi est ce que je vénère et
pourquoi être je vénère parce qu'il est
nous ne sommes pas son élu mais il est
notre élu ce dieu de bonté ce dieu des
dessins commandement nous l'avons créée
c'est pourquoi m
il doit vous y croyez j'y crois comme
vous des jeux le révère il y là
l'existence que le peuple d'israël lui a
donné mais pourtant cessé pour moi la
projection dans le ciel du tempérament
de prophétique
vous semblez tantôt ils croient tantôt
ne pas je suis un hébreu inconséquent ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire
tout en ne croyant pas j'y crois je peux
pas vous dire autre chose tout en y
voyant pas j'y crois quel regard jetez
vous sur notre siècle notre vingtième
siècle un certain point de vue j'ai
l'impression d'une effroyable des
cadences à d'autres points de vue là
progrès s'endorment
j'attends la fin du monde non c'est ce
que je dis là les radios mais c'est vrai
c'est pour la première fois qu'une
espèce animale a la possibilité de se
détruire
elle s'en servira donc vous croyez à la
au suicide de l'humanité puis toujours
espérer qu'il existera un olympe prêt à
accueillir des hommes aussi
exceptionnelle que vous vous savez je
voudrais mourir comme socrate un vrai
qu'ils ne savaient pas ce qu'ils
l'attendaient il eu de josé houde bien
ce sera un sommeil éternel qu'est ce qui
est plus agréable qu'une surveillance
monde ou bien j'irai aux champs elysées
je parlerai que mère je ne crois pas je
crois plutôt sommeil total mais je
verrai vous serez enlevé brutalement par
les dieux allemand voulait lire et j'ai
souvent ce désir de tout brûler à vous
avez pas volé les lignes qui sont là
devant pas maintenant mais met alors un
jour il m'a pris j'ai tout brûler
pourquoi je vais faire une bêtise ou je
vous crois mon souvenir même prix alors
j'ai dire une grosse bêtise
ah oui une grosse béquille enfin pour
moi que c'était une bêtise
il en fait c'était un péché un gros
péché
oh oui elle fut pas obligés je vous
confie cela non non non alors je suis
rentré en moi même et j'ai dit il faut
que tu détruis tout ça parce que tu vas
dire ce que tu as fait et ce sera au
déshonneur et j'ai tout détruit mais
c'est de ce feu purificateur qu'est née
votre oeuvre
c'est y tarification parce que je ne
voulais pas faire état de monter chez
c'est dieu qui vous commande s ah ah oui
c'était pour plaire à dieu que au pas ce
que dieu pour moi c'est tout est-ce que
vous priez beaucoup à je prie ça oui le
soir ma prière du soir c'est super pour
moi
quelle est cette prière ces âmes de chez
crise amplifié mois corps de
jésus-christ
sauvez moi sans jésus christ on lit
vraiment haut du côté de chez du gris
lave et moi passions jésus-christ
fortifiée mois puis après c'est cash et
moi allons doubler chez afin que dans
l'éternité je puisse vous aimez avec vos
seins
très émouvante cette prière dite par
marcel jouhandeau huitième et dernier
bouquet de mots je vais commencer par
pierre miquel oublie parce que sans
oublier ya pas de mémoire
son mémoire il n'y a pas d'histoire mais
surtout quand même très dommage gilles
lapouge neige c'est l'enfance c'est le
blin c'est le silence c'est provisoire
et puis ça revient l'année suivante
gabriel matzneff j'hésite entre icônes
et iconoclaste parce que cette
hésitation est à l'image de ma vie et de
l'avis de tous ceux qui sont entre
l'amour et la destruction de l'amour
voilà qui savent pas philippe sollers
je prendrai joie passer un vieux beau
français et c'est le signe dit spinoza
d'une montée de perfection perfection et
voit la joie
julia kristeva c'est le mot étranger en
raison de sa sonorité d'abord écouté
étrangers rage étranglée au fond de ma
gorge ange noir brisant votre
transparence ainsi de suite aussi parce
que étrangement l'étranger nous habite
et à force de le reconnaître en nous
peut-être nous épargnera de le
persécuter en lui-même
et enfin parce qu'on a rarement réuni
autant d'étrangeté comme ce soir claude
mauriac hervé renard on m'avait un peu
déçu ces jours ci je suis sûr que les
attriste et beaucoup de vos amis si
quelqu'un avait dû protester contre la
suppression si la triste ans de l'acteur
circonflexe et bien vous qu'est ce que
c'est que le move août par exemple sur
le petit toit qu'il protège et il
s'écroule et abîme je vous le dis je
suis sûr que beaucoup de nos amis de vos
amis pensent à leurs jumeaux il y en a
deux la tourterelle et espérance jeunes
champions et bien moi j'ai choisi le mot
âme en souhaitant que l'homme en est une
louis nucéra le mot aux nuances parce
que je trouve qu'il ya une belle
sonorité et puis parce qu'ils nous
obligent
à maîtriser la violence les intolérances
que nous avons en nous marcel jullian
complices mais il est difficile de dire
pourquoi tout le monde
suzanne rouler moi je pense que je vais
choisir le mot fleurs quoique y en ait
d'autres qui me plaisent comme opale
comme mosaïque ou caravansérail mais
choisit fleurs parce que c'est beau
comme son et ça évoque quelque chose de
vaud et de jeunes jean-daniel ferveur
parce qu'il oppose le désir la mort
claude hagège linguiste mes mots
fétiches sont rois l'unss et éternité
et voici un district de ma façon pour
l'illustrer
te voilà parvenu presque à l'éternité
pivot qui pour le livre attend
crapahuter il s'intitule triaire
d'incinérer l'autre c'est un couple avec
souvenirs et espoir apostrophe déjà
nourri le souvenir mais l'espoir nous
promet un jour d'y revenir
c'est très joli je suis très sensible
françoise chandernagor choisi le mot
mélancolie foucras sonorités liquide
fluide et aussi parce qu'ils entrent
dans un des plus beaux verres de la
langue française
valse mélancolique et langoureux vertige
ça me paraît très français mon voisin
dirai peut-être que ce ne sont pas des
sonorités typiques du français roger
stéphane j'avais choisi intelligence
parce que c'est une vertu et qu'il y à
aussi être d'intelligence avec quelqu'un
ou avec l'ennemi mais on a parlé de
vérité tout à l'heure et de gide
je voudrais citer l'amour de la vérité
n'est pas le besoin de certitudes et il
est bien imprudent de confondre l'un
avec l'autre
dernière séquence l'éloge de la lecture
par deux grandes comédiennes fanny
ardant et jeanne moreau une question
d'amour quand vous quand vous prenez un
roman comme ça je ne sais pas quel est
votre état d'esprit qu'est ce que vous
attendez d'une lecture j'attends d'être
mis ailleurs qu on me parle d'une chose
ou que je connais ou que je ne connais
pas j'aime bien venir vérifier des
obsessions que j'ai en moi même pour
savoir si je suis la seule à penser
quelque chose oui prouver quelque chose
j'aime bien diverti j'aime bien avoir
une émotion et j'aime bien lire
justement n'importe quoi je ne dis pas
je lis que les romains ou je lis que des
romans policiers
non le pire comme le meilleur à travers
la lecture j'ai appris la liberté la
liberté intérieure être intouchable
avoir un univers secret et puis
communiquée dans la lecture
il y a des moments où on se cherche et
on se trouve
et ça c'était pas tant tout d'un coup on
peut s'identifier à certaines paroles
qu'on trouve imprimés et on a un
soulagement énorme on dit 1
il a dit cela tellement bien et c'est ce
que je ressens mais que je n'arrivais
pas à bien dire à bien définir
et puis il ya d'autres moments dans la
lecture ou ce sont des portes qui
s'ouvrent
par contre on ne se trouve pas mais on
détruire un autre univers on part en
voyage
merci jeu l'émission touche à sa fin je
dois lancer une première salle de
remerciements aux gens qui sont là et
je commençais par jacqueline baudrier
qui m'a fait faire mes débuts à la
télévision alors qu'elle dirigeait la
première chaîne à côté d'elle marcel
jullian président fondateur d'antenne 2
sous la hotte sous la douce autorités
duquel j'ai commencé à commencer à
apostrophes derrière claude barma qui a
ouvré les guillemets a été mon premier
réalisateur philippe chatel qui
représente son père françois chatel que
j'aimais beaucoup et qui a été le
premier réalisateur d' apostrophes roger
kahn qui a été chronologiquement le
deuxième réalisateur d' apostrophes je
crois que c'est la quatrième émission
qu'il a commencé jacques cristobal qui a
fait quelques apostrophes mais qui était
surtout le réalisateur d'un poste et
deux strophes nicolas rimouski qui a été
le réalisateur de tous les tête à tête
chez les écrivains illustre c'est à dire
chez cauet che yourcenar chez
lévi-strauss chez jouhandeau etc
jean cazenave qui est le réalisateur qui
a fait le plus de postroff 324
exactement et c'est aussi jean cazenave
et des de françoise shaddai ac qui a
monté tout les séquences d'archivés que
vous venez de voir ben michel millecamps
il est resté près de son de son mur et
enfin en régie parce qu'il est aux
manettes ce soir c'est jean-luc léridon
qui sert des ces dernières années
faisait apostrophe en alternance avec
cazenave et je voudrais profiter la
circonstance pour remercier tout le
personnel technique et administratif
d'antenne 2 certains techniciens ont
fait plusieurs centaines d' apostrophes
et ainsi que le personnel technique de
la sfp malheureusement grève pour des
raisons très grave avec qui il m'est
arrivé de travailler alors je vous
entends j'ai intentionnellement et et
les spectacles qui se disent mais c'est
bizarre il nous a encore pas montrer une
seule image de la première émission d'
apostrophes c'est quand même bizarre
et bien voilà ce qui s'est passé il
n'existe aucune image des neuf premières
émissions d' apostrophes aucune
et bien simplement il ya eu un oubli il
ya eu un oubli techniques et n'ont pas
été enregistrés c'était la dixième
seulement qu'un
directeur technique s'est dit mais
est-ce qu'on enregistre apostrophes et
on lui a dit non et c'était d'ailleurs
le choix de la 10e c'est celle où vous
avez vu bigeard et brassens alors donc
cette première émission n'existe pas et
c'est dommage parce qu'on peut la
première évidemment la troisième qui
était sur la chine où il y avait jean
pasqualini et le premier témoignage sur
les camps maoïste la cinquième qui est
extraordinaire parce que c'était
françois les télés les lectures de
françois mitterrand et il était à ce
moment là il n'est pas président de la
république et il avait été vraiment
éblouissant dans sa manière de parler
des écrivains qu'il aimait jules renard
boutaty et bien d'autres alors cette
première émission et bien voici les
rescapés de cette première mission parce
qu'il s'agit tuer les avocats dont il
pas facilement bonne conscience il y
avait m emile polak qui malheureusement
est décédé il y avait m rené floriot qui
est décédé et il y avait mon ami gilles
lapouge six avocats et qu'il n'est pas
le cas mais qu'il n'assistait dans les
premières émissions
il y avait m charles libman qui est la
leur fille sanglier un livre justice
impossible et puis paul le faire qui est
à ce moment-là chroniqueur sur antenne 2
et qui faisait qui est publié un livre
intitulé serviteur de la justice et puis
il y avait aussi un autre personnage
dont je ne peux pas donner le nom je
l'appellerai claude c'est qu'ils étaient
là c'est un ancien condamné à mort qui
avait publié un ouvrage intitulé le
maximum où il racontait ses souvenirs et
qui est un homme totalement réhabilité
qui a fait des études de droit et qui
devait était devenir juriste qui a
d'ailleurs dirigé une excellente revue
de l'un qui veut redonner au gil c'est
ça alors il a préféré ne pas venir ce
soir parce que après cette émission il
ya donc 15 ans et bien sa femme a été en
butte à l'hostilité de pas mal de gens
qui d'un seul coup ont découvert qu'elle
était l'épousé d'un ancien condamné à
mort donc elle n'a pas envie de revivre
ce calvaire et je la comprends très bien
alors est ce que m iman caisse plus à
garder un souvenir de cette émission
j'ai gardé un souvenir extrêmement
précis notamment d'une altercation entre
rené floriot qui était l'avocat
tout le monde a connu ici je pense un
des plus grands pénalistes de l'après
guerre et qui compte tenu peut-être d'un
état de santé qui le chatouille est
quelque peu à ce moment là n'a pas
supporté les critiques de cet ancien
détenu qui avait écrit un livre au terme
duquel il faisait quelques critiques à
la fois sur la justice et sur quelques
avocats et nonobstant la qualité de
florio il avait remarqué que florio
n'allait pas aussi souvent qu'ils
pouvaient le souhaitait que les détenus
pouvaient lé souhaitait en prison et
florio n'a pas supporté il ya eu une
altercation il ya eu et il y ait eu une
altercation au terme de laquelle florio
a dit et puis je ne parle pas moi un
condamné à mort ce qui paraissait tout
de même quelque peu insolite et
inopportun de la part du défenseur
oui des criminels que nous connaissons
il est vrai aussi qu aussitôt me
semble-t-il fun le fun il me semble que
m plaqués et vous m lienemann nous est
venue un peu au secours mais j'avais
fait ça avait fait un peu scandale
surtout que l'on s'était bien rendu
compte que florio avait dépassé de
certaines limites et que claude c était
un petit peu allez allez je crois que ça
allait éclater encore plus donc on avait
un petit peu appeler aux pompiers oui et
vous même mais c'est vrai que ça avait
été et en plus de ça je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui me kim tout à l'heure
en repensant cette émission d'abord
j'étais apprécié d'être un ancêtre de
cette académie au sens premier du mot
finalement mais surtout quelque chose
qui va frapper le sujet de cette
première émission il ya 15 ans c'était
les avocats cité les problèmes de la
justice
ben alors je me suis blanc me tu dis que
finalement depuis cette émission y'a pas
grand chose qui a changé
les problèmes sont toujours les mêmes
gilles lapouge est-ce que vous avez
gardé un souvenir de l'altercation oui
j'avais retenu notre formule semble que
florio lui avait dit vous dites que vous
voulez devenir avocat mais nous
n'acceptons pas n'importe qui exact
et vous
vous êtes avocat voilà la vette ajouté
oui et vous pourtant vous êtes avocat
oui je me rappelle ça m'échappe
complètement c'est pourquoi j'étais là
ils vont parler je faisais ça parce qu'à
ce moment là je faisais toutes les
fragilités vous renseigner donc je sais
que je n'ai pas démissionné
et alors quoi tomber c'était très
bientôt alors je peux vous dire aussi
ses cadets cependant des téléspectateurs
qu'ils disent mais ça a dû être
enregistrés
mais non parce que les magnétoscopes
individuel n'existait pas en 1975 donc
c'est parce qu'un produit c'est que j'ai
fait les neuf premières émissions et
puis après j'avais trouvé faire en
amazonie et je suis parti voilà alors je
n'ai absolument aucun coup j'ai
absolument privées de mémoire d'
apostrophes
les témoignages sont si fragiles que
lefebvre ne se souvenait pas de ma
présence et que je ne me souvenais pas
de la présence de le faire aller mais on
est amis quand même ça pour vous mettre
fragilité des témoignages oui voila
merci deuxième deuxième volet de
remerciement alors d'abord félicitation
pour madame brigitte deux taux qui a
gagné le concours à post savait qu'il y
avait un concours sur le minitel 36 15
coda peut savoir quel si vous avez une
bonne mémoire des décès 723 émissions d'
apostrophes et c'est vous qui avez gagné
donc je suppose que vous avez regardé
souvent cette émission j'ai appris que
vous êtes parisienne enseignante et je
vous remercie de votre fidélité et de
votre bonne mémoire alors des
remerciements à à monique van ling qui
bat était ancienne assistante cinq
colonnes à la une qui a été l'assistante
la première assistante de réalisation d'
apostrophes jusqu'à ce que pierre
desgraupes quand il est devenu le patron
de la chaîne vous la fasse monter à la
direction
elisabeth sort au caire qui a été
longtemps la scripte de l'émission
derrière rené bernard qui a succédé à
monique 20 de link comme assistante de
réalisation à côté de rodez bernard
anne-marie bourgnon mon assistante
depuis bientôt 20 ans voilà bravo
[Applaudissements]
alors vraiment je suis très content que
vous l'ayez applaudi et comme ça sans
que je vous demandais rien parce que non
parce que simplement anne marie est très
populaire auprès des éditeurs et des
écrivains
parce que c'est elle qui reçoit toutes
les doléances toutes les complaintes et
c'est grâce à elle mais grâce à sa
courtoisie que je peux lire
chez moi tranquillement sans me soucier
de tous les problèmes
voilà donc je veux maintenant rendent
hommage aux attachés de presse parce que
j'ai travaillé avec elle pendant 25 ans
je pense qu'on vienne enfin partir
membre depuis 15 ans avec apostrophe à
travers trois d'entre elles mais qui
n'exerce plus monique maillot et qui tu
es chez grasset françoise lambert qui
était chez laffont et paul de l'église
chez gallimard et je profite pour faire
un signe amical à serge montigny qui lui
était le chef du service de de presse
éditions du seuil grâce à qui j'ai pu
avoir ce génie tsin sur mon plateau
et puis d'autres françois fin des
remerciements alors encore plus privé
plus particulier madame reversât qui est
la gardienne de mon immeuble et qui
depuis 20 ans ma montée des tonnes et
des tonnes de livres tous les livres
arrivée par la poste c'est elle qui les
a montées à côté d'elle
andré berger qui était cycliste pour
l'ensemble des maisons d'édition et qui
lui aussi depuis 15 ans m'a monté des
tonnes et des tonnes de livres de tout
ce qui venait directement de chez les
éditeurs et puis madame yvonne le bar
qui est une téléspectatrice assidue mais
à 6,8 à mot faible puisqu'elle a vu les
723 émissions d' apostrophes et donc
même les 724 aujourd'hui ça ça mérite
des applaudissements
merci évidemment pour pour votre
assiduité votre confiance madame le bar
mais je sais qu'un jour vous avez failli
rater une émission qu'est ce qui s'est
passé m'a proposé de me faire cette
opération le vendredi je lui dis non
absolument pas on me dit vous êtes juste
père this yeuse pas du tout mais je ne
veux pas rater moines apostrophes et de
ce fait on a remis de l'opération
merci voilà c'est un beau témoignage
aussi depuis des vitesses
bravo et puis enfin et je terminerai
avec lui bien arabe qui présentera dès
la rentrée sur antenne 2 une émission
sur les livres je lui passerait donc le
relais et je lui souhaite d'ores et déjà
bonne chance
[Applaudissements]
voudrais vous montrer alors des choses
qui ont rapport avec apostrophe les
éditions du seuil et lina met en vente
des cassettes qui ne sont disponibles
qu'en librairie des cassettes d'
apostrophes vous y en a quatre qui
viennent de sortir le nabokov dont vous
avez vu un extrait il ya un instant
marguerite yourcenar aussi donc vous
avez vu un extrait et puis deux autres
de que je n'ai pas pu présenter mais il
y en a beaucoup d'autres que l'entretien
le tête à tête avec julien green et le
tête à tête chez lui avec georges
simenon
et puis enfin si vous vous demandez pour
comment se faire ça commence à marcher
apostrophe qu'elle était l'esprit de
l'émission qu'est-ce que comment je
travaillais bien j'ai répondu dans la
dernière venue méreau de la revue le
débat aux questions pertinentes de
pierre nora et voilà ce 700 24e et
dernier numéro d' apostrophes est
terminée générique de fin d'émission
pour la dernière fois vous allez
entendre la musique de rachmaninoff
bonsoir à tous et à l'année prochaine
[Musique]